[Musique]
foyers français soyez niveau nous allons
créer la surprise je vous le promets
le mépris de classe d'un côté le bleu
pris de rage de l'autre eh bien non je
rendrai leur argent français je rentrais
leur pays aux français
[Applaudissements]
des auteurs antisémite d'autres raciste
convaincu par les idées avec respect
[Musique]
bonjour mesdames et messieurs bons
dimanches bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale entourant le premier tour de la
présidentielle française les français
ont connu une campagne bizarre avec des
changements de rythme important jamais
par ailleurs l'extrême droite n'aurait
été aussi près du réel pouvoir marine le
pen sera probablement au deuxième tour
contre 1 emmanuel matheron macron qui a
dû redescendre sur terre il y a quelques
jours pour faire finalement campagne
quant aux partis traditionnels
les socialistes ou la droite
républicaine ils sont en lambeaux très
loin derrière on va analyser ces
phénomènes bien sûr ça concerne cette
campagne électorale les résultats bien
sûr d'abord et avant tout les français
ça concerne les français d'ici qui sont
allés voter on n'a pas de tout à l'heure
à montréal et ailleurs au pays en
amérique du nord mais ça concerne aussi
pas mal de monde l'europe la planète si
marine le pen devient présidente si
manuel macron reste président ça ne sera
pas les mêmes politiques étrangères donc
c'est un impact sur nos vies également
ici la règle aujourd'hui et cinq des
douze candidats qui ont entrepris la
course il y a plusieurs semaines ils ne
seront plus que deux ce soir nous
connaîtrons ici à notre heure les
résultats à 14 heures nous iront
rejoindre nos correspondants sur le
terrain dans le camp macron et le pen en
direct très souvent cet après midi nous
serons aussi je le disais sur le terrain
à montréal où les français vous les avez
peut-être entendu
je vais employer le mot russe péter hier
parce que regarder ces lignes encore une
fois comme en 2010 est ça a été très
long on parlera d'ailleurs à la consul
de france à montréal pourquoi on
n'arrive pas organiser les choses de
manière un peu plus efficace avec moi
sur le plateau on sera sur le terrain
beaucoup en france mais sur le plateau
hélène jouan que je vous présente
correspondante pour le ondées radio
france à montréal hélène bonjour bonjour
merci d'être ici avec nous mathieu prost
mathieu journalistes vous suivez
évidemment avec beaucoup de passion ce
qui se passe ça va lire bicéphale en
france bien alors on va ensemble
expliquer ce système là vous allez nous
présenter aussi des clés d'analysé pour
comprendre ce qui se passe sur tout ce
qui va se passer michel serrault jettent
à paris ta tombe bien comme on dit
michel bonsoir à vous
alors je commence avec un premier tour
de table rapide michel je commence avec
vous j'ai fait un bon papier ce matin
dans la presse jupiter le surnom de
macron vous dites en deux mots qu'il a
dû redescendre sur terre c'est une
campagne on en a parlé un peu plus tôt
cette semaine qui a changé
dramatiquement depuis 15 10 jours
ou écouter c'est d'abord cette campagne
qui a commencé avec la coved qui se
termine avec l'ukraine c'est quand même
pas banal et deuxièmement monsieur bakr
on a été vraiment absent de la campagne
quand il s'est réveillé pour commencer à
faire campagne pour vrai il s'est mis à
perdre n 1 fois par semaine pendant ce
temps là madame le pen gagne un point
par semaine grosso modo alors c'est
de toute évidence monsieur m'a compte
pas c'est que être le président de
guerre sale est bien servi au début de
la campagne de ça allait fonctionner
mais avec le temps ça a moins bien
fonctionné et le thème du pouvoir
d'achat de l'inflation de la hausse des
prix a pris beaucoup plus de place que
je pense tout le monde l'avait pensé
c'est au final le pen qui avait fait 200
depuis déjà quelques semaines son
principal thème de chemins de campagne
et c'est ça qui l'a aidé à probablement
bien finir ce soir très bien hélène
qu'est-ce que vous surveillez en
particulier dans les prochaines heures
le score est la place de marine le pen
parce que c'est sa troisième candidature
à une élection présidentielle 2012 2017
elle n'avait pas été au second tour en
2012 elle est au second tour en 2017 est
là pour la première fois elle avait été
quand même encore écrasé en 2017 après
un un débat d'entre deux tours très
mauvais conclut emmanuel macron mais là
pour la première fois
il est possible en tout cas les derniers
sondages montré qu'il était possible que
marine le pen accède au pouvoir et c'est
ça l'enjeu est peut-être la surprise de
cette élection présidentielle personne
n'y croyait lui encore quelques semaines
on en est là c'est certainement ce soir
exactement il ya trois semaines mais
c'est lui qui allait qui aurait dit que
le pen aurait peut-être été au terme du
deuxième tour présidente vendresse
voyons simplement les chiffres de monde
pense à ça manque c'est imprévisible sur
place tout au long de cet après-midi
politique raphaël bouvier au clair à
paris vous êtes au rassemblement des
manuels macron et hanegbi euros vous
êtes au rassemblement dans le camp de
marine le pen dont on va beaucoup parler
évidemment forcément aujourd'hui raphaël
bouvier je commence avec vous
effectivement il a dû redescendre sur
terre assez vite et commence à faire
campagne je m'accroche
et il a commencé à faire campagne
effectivement très tard patrice parce
que au cours des derniers mois l'homme
qu'on a vu devant les caméras dans les
médias s'étaient emmanuel macron le chef
d'état celui qui passe des coups de fil
à volodimir zelensky le président
ukrainien celui qui entretient la
conversation avec vladimir poutine le
président russe et ça avait contribué à
une hausse à un certain moment dans les
sondages emmanuel macron mais depuis
cette hausse s'est essoufflée et
finalement on a vu cette avance d'
emmanuel macron diminuer au profit d'une
montée de marine le pen ce qui fait en
sorte que oui on a dû accélérer le
rythme de campagne il ya eu par exemple
un grand rassemblement samedi dernier
pas hier mais la semaine précédente à la
défense près de 30000 personnes qui se
sont réunies mais il était déjà très
tard on était déjà patrice en france
soumis à des règles très strictes en
matière de diffusion donc tous les
médias français devait diffuser le même
temps pour les 12 candidats peu importe
leur position dans les sondages qui fera
en sorte que ce seul et unique grand
rassemblement de campagne emmanuel
macron a été publiée ou diffusée de
manière plutôt réduite dans les médias
traditionnels que ce soit la télé ou la
radio monsieur macron a aussi refuser de
débattre avec ses adversaires ya pas eu
de débat des douze candidats au premier
tour à la présidentielle ce que n'ont
pas manqué de lui rappeler reprocher ses
adversaires et finalement il a commencé
à accorder plus d'entrevues au cours de
la semaine mais on voit finalement que
tout ça est arrivé en fin de campagne
alors qu'on commençait à parler
davantage michel il faisait référence au
thème du pouvoir d'achat nous on s'est
beaucoup promené en france au cours des
dernières semaines des derniers mois et
le thème du pouvoir d'achat il est
revenu à la bouche de nombreux électeurs
et ajoutez à cela aussi un scandale pour
lequel le gouvernement de monsieur
macron a dû se défendre celui de
mécaniser c'est à dire qu'on a reproché
au gouvernement français d'avoir passé
des contrats des centaines de millions
d'euros de contrat à une firme de
cabinets conseils qui fait l'objet de
critiques et d'une enquête pour ses
pratiques fiscales tout ça et même bien
en fin de campagne dont vous voyez un
peu le portrait de cette fin de campagne
du président sortant lui qui a quelques
semaines à peine était au haut des
sondages très très loin devant ses
adversaires dont marine le pen oui il il
pensait pouvoir faire l'économie d'une
campagne électorale a pas amené beaucoup
beaucoup de grandes nouvelles idées on
se alors les gens commençaient à dire
dans le fond est ce que les sujets qui
nous préoccupent le coût de la vie vous
l'avez dit beaucoup est-ce qu'il est le
président la c6 revenus des riches où il
est notre président ça ne l'a pas aidé
on l'a entendu cette semaine la part
d'une lectrice en normandie macron c'est
le président des riches est une image
qui lui colle à la peau auprès d'une
certaine partie de l'électorat en tout
cas on entendu au cours des derniers
jours emmanuel macron faire des
propositions pour affronter donc cette
inflation cette augmentation du coût de
la vie qui est vraiment sondage après
sondage la priorité des français à des
promesses au niveau de la retraite
promesses de prime aux travailleurs
aussi tous arrivés au cours des derniers
jours mais la grande promesse qui
revenue aussi de laquelle on parle
beaucoup des manuels macron c'est celle
d'augmenter le seuil du passage à la
retraite de le faire passer à 65 ans
d'un chantier qui avait été entrepris
qui n'a pas été terminé dans le premier
quinquennat et ça c'est une promesse qui
plaît à certains mais qui suscite aussi
beaucoup beaucoup de critiques notamment
à gauche c'est cette promesse l'a
finalement qui est resté dans les
discours et dans les analyses médiatique
au cours des derniers jours raphaël 20
secondes est ce qu'on craint vraiment de
l'échappée vous croyez
bah écoutez on a entendu en tout cas
emmanuel macron certains de ses proches
dire qu'il y avait un réel risque que
l'extrême droite passe pour deuxième
tour non seulement mais aussi obtiennent
le pouvoir l'elysée il ya une
possibilité de report de vote pour
marine le pen cette fois ci si elles
l'emportent et on a donc entendu
emmanuel macron critiquer certaines
personnes qui auraient contribué à
dédiaboliser très bons adversaires au
cours des cinq dernières années
clairement on sait que cette possibilité
là elle est là mais on va avoir des
indices ce soir évidemment avec les les
résultats il faudra revoir la stratégie
pour le deuxième tour merci à tous tués
à tout de suite pianic vous êtes dans le
cas de madame le pen qui a fait en tout
cas at elle fait une bonne campagne je
vais laisser mes analyses nous en parler
tout au long de l'après-midi mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que ça a été efficace
zemmour eu la flemme par est beaucoup
plus douce elle n'a pas parlé
d'immigration à parler du coût de la vie
elle était donc au diapason des
préoccupations de beaucoup de
l'électorat français
voilà à patrice une campagne de
proximité
marine le pen a fait vous savez sans
faire beaucoup de bruit le tour de
france des petites villes des villages
pour aller voir les français qui sont
très occupés par le pouvoir d'achat le
vraiment immédiatement ciblé 7 grandes
préoccupations des français donc aller
voir les français les françaises
inquiets de voir les prix flambent et on
parle de l'essence mais aussi les prix
de consommation préoccupé par les
délocalisations à voir la difficulté à
joindre les boules à la fin du mois donc
une campagne vraiment plus sous le radar
je vous dirais jusqu'aux dernières
semaines et on dit que peut-être que les
caisses du rassemblement national
n'était peut-être pas assez garni c'est
ce que certains observateurs disent pour
pouvoir tenir de grands événements comme
celui qu'on a vu entre autres à
perpignan là quelques jours de la fin du
second tour et marine le pen ont dit
aussi qu'elle s'était économisé 1 alors
conservé ses énergies pour ne pas finir
épuisé comme en 2017 vous savez
l'épuisement qui aurait peut-être
contribué une de vous inviter en parler
au fait qu'elle ait connu un débat tout
à fait désastreux face à emmanuel macron
donc ça c'était en tenant un entre-deux
tours donc une campagne tout à fait
différente et aussi le fait que l est
davantage parler d'elle même par les
plus de la personne que la politiciens
pour être peut-être plus accessible et
peut-être plus humaine et ce face à eric
zemmour
et bien qu'ils avaient un ton plus
clivants ton plus dur et bien elle
pouvait passer pour plus modéré plus
posé et on a rencontré des partisans de
nouveaux partisans qui disait nous on
n'avait jamais cru un jour voté pour un
le pen que ce soit pour le père ou pour
la fille mais maintenant quand on voit
ce que eric zemmour proposé qu'on voit
que marine le pen veut rendre de la
france aux français voeu de toutes les
décisions soient prises dans l'intérêt
des français qu'elle parle des jeunes et
bien que nous cette fois ci on va voter
le pen elle était confiante je matin
d'ailleurs
oui tout à fait vous savez cette
confiance on la sent chez partisans
depuis quelques jours en regardant les
sondages comment ne pas être optimiste
de ce côté là quoique le vrai verdict
c'est aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs au
rassemblement à perpignan le maire louis
aliot qui du rassemblement national on
sentait clairement que le parti visait
la campagne second tour il avait même
dit aux partisans attention le ballet
les 15 prochains jours ils vont devra
être calme on devra être déterminé il
faudra pas céder aux attaques qui vont
sûrement à venir de l'autre quand il
disait et je le cite que le système est
aux abois et en allant voter aujourd'hui
plutôt à hénin-beaumont marine le pen
c'était dans son fief dans le pas de
calais dans le nord de la france et bien
elle a serré des mains elle a prié d
hugo portrait un petit bain de foule
mais voici ce qu'elle a déclaré après
avoir voté
l'investissement de de l'ombre
du combat et puis
je vous dire quelque chose qui vous
prête à utiliser on espère qu'elle
durera il manquait
alors vous le dis elle s'est éloignée
des thèmes de l'immigration de
l'insécurité qui étaient les thèmes
dominants au front national à l'époque
que rassembleur nationale et elle a
parlé d'économie de taxe sur l'essence
des des choses qui sont chères d'enlever
la taxe la tva en france sur les biens
essentiels ll a voulu changer les thèmes
forts de sa campagne
voilà quand même sur la forme parce que
ça le soudan le sud font ses positions
restent quand même assez proche d'eric
zemmour du parti et reconquête que ce
soit sur l'immigration elle entendue
durant son dernier grand discours là à
perpignan mais sur la forme et aussi
dans son approche elle a voulu montrer
dire aux français que moi présidente je
vais mieux prendre soin de vous je vais
vraiment me préoccupe et je vais à votre
écoute parce qu'une des critiques envers
emmanuel macron séquelles il était
peut-être trop loin des préoccupations
des français elle a dit non moi je suis
là et on sent que c'est la candidate
l'emmène en est à sa troisième campagne
elle a appris de ses erreurs et
d'ailleurs louis aliot le maire de
perpignan dont je vous parlais et pour
le site et il dit que marine le pen
vraiment depuis a appris de certaines la
tirer des leçons de certaines de ses
erreurs elle est plus déterminée elle a
beaucoup plus d'expérience cette fois-ci
qu'en 2006 année qu'une petite question
plus légère si vous me permettez il
semble faire beau
j'ai passé sur toute la france mais quel
temps fait-il ça aide ça le la
participation on peut rire mais c'est
oui peut-être vous savez marine le pen
l'avait dit aussi sortait boîte est allé
voter il va faire d'ailleurs beau
dimanche oui il fait beau est ce que
c'était le cas partout sur la france est
bien les images qui nous parviennent
c'était plutôt doux ça peut être
favorisé le vote on verra mais vous
savez le taux d'abstention quand même
est assez élevé donc est-ce que ça a
vraiment joué peut-être ça a joué chez
ses partisans ont leur hôpital quand on
aura les résultats à décortiquer et si
vous êtes dehors c'est pascal un thé y a
pas encore de partisans la
voilà je me trouve sur la terrasse du
pavillon ou à vrai dire il ya beaucoup
plus de caméras de micros de
journalistes que de partisans qu'on
attend peut-être d'une minute à l'autre
on sait que marine le pen a quitté il ya
quelques minutes son qg pour venir ici
suivre la soirée des élections et où on
se trouvait bien on est à l'orée du bois
de vincennes pour ceux qui connaissent
paris donc un petit peu à l'extérieur de
paris est donc décor tout à fait
champêtre mais à l'intérieur quand ça va
commencer quand les résultats vont
commencer à tomber eh bien ça serait
peut-être plus chaud à l'intérieur mais
pour l'instant vous savez on attend
toujours les militants et on attend la
candidate de rassemblement national à
plus tard indique merci beaucoup d'être
là avec nous cet après midi mathieu
proches je disais une campagne bizarre
c'est une campagne où il ya eu
inversement de tendance
totalement une campagne bizarre beaucoup
disent parle d'une drôle de campagne
pour les deux compagnies une référence
un peu à la drôle de guerre c'est
patrice en 1939 quand la guerre était
déclarée contre l'allemagne qui s'est
rien passé pendant des mois mais c'est
un peu ça ait eu peu d'enthousiasmé
pendant des mois pour cette campagne et
ça c'est un petit peu accéléré en fin de
campagne quand on disait le mot campagne
il y a trois mois à peu près on pensait
à la campagne de vaccination parce qu'on
était encore dans la vague au micron
puis emmanuel macron disait d'ailleurs
que l'un de ses souhaits c'était
d'emmerdés entre guillemets les non
vaccinés il l'avait dit dans une
entrevue très officiellement sa psy lui
a permis de retarder son entrée en
campagne et effectivement raphaël en
parler aussi la guerre en ukraine
déclenchée fin février lui a permis de
prendre de la hauteur cet aspect
jupitérien comme il le disait ce
président au dessus de la mêlée 10 ne
s'occupe pas de politique politicienne
et effectivement on l'a vu multiplié les
coups de fil notamment au président
poutine qui l'a mis un peu en scène ses
coups de fil à sa lui étaient reprochés
même dans son entourage certains lui
disais à arrêter de passer des coups de
fils avait dit routine occupez vous de
la campagne donc il s'est tenu à
distance mais il a été obligé de rentrer
évidemment dans la mêlée dans la partie
ça a été reproché cette distance-là par
tous les candidats qu'il n'y a pas eu de
débat il a refusé débattre avec les 11
autres candidats ce n'est pas une
surprise c'est une habitude compris les
présidents sortants de ne pas aller en
direct à la télévision pour pour
débattre coup d'oeil vous dites aux
sondages d'intentions de vote que ce qui
est intéressant c'est l'évolution depuis
les dernières semaines ce une agrégation
qui a été réalisé par claire durand du
département de sociologie de l'udem
merci pour la gracieuseté vous voyez ce
qui est très clair c'est deux coups
trois courbes qui descendent eric
zemmour valérie pécresse et emmanuel
macron c'est très nette depuis la fin
février début mars il est en train de
s'approcher de marine le pen qui monte
et la deuxième courbe qui monte c'est la
rouge ici jean luc mélenchon donc
effectivement on s'attend à ce que ce
soit serré au final regarder les
projections de deuxième tour cet
hypothétique dans le cas où marine le
pen et emmanuel macron seraient
qualifiés et bien ça se resserre
extrêmement depuis la début le début du
mois de mars on est à environ 50 2 48 et
tout ça c'est à peu près patrice dans
les marges d'erreur des sondeurs coup
d'oeil aux seuls chiffres qu'on a pour
l'instant qui est la participation à 17h
heure de paris participe participation à
65% 65% ces quatre points de moins que
2017 mais c'est plus haut que 2002 qui
était le record d'abstention pour une
présidentielle voilà parce que la
présidentielle taux de participation
hélène habituellement est élevé plus
élevé il faut le dire aux gens qui nous
écoutent ici que pour nos élections
fédérales ou provinciales
nous on a régulièrement pour reprendre
votre façon de le montrer 38 %
d'abstention au canada la dernière la
dernière élection fédérale c'est 60 2%
le taux de participation et les jambons
on le note or les gens s'en plaignent
mais pas autant chez vous l'élection
présidentielle
c'est important que sas d'abstention ne
flirte pas les 30%
l'élection présidentielle ça reste
l'élection reine chez nous c'est pour
dire à quel point on est encore dans une
démocratie démocratie peut-être un peu
monarchique mais c'est vrai qu'en gros
ça tourne l'abstention tourne autour de
20 % et puis il ya eu un accident dans
l'histoire c'est la présidentielle de
2002 celle qui a éliminé le candidat
socialiste dès le premier tour pour
laisser passer le candidat le père de
marine le pen jean-marie le pen et à ce
moment-là l'abstention était à 28,1 4 %
c'est un record absolu pour l'instant
dans l'histoire de la vème république et
des scrutins pour la présidentielle et
forcément ça va avoir un impact ça va
avoir un impact pour chacun des
candidats puisque on sait qu'il ya une
abstention différentiel alors derrière
ce terme un peu barbare ça veut dire
qu'on sait qu'il y est il y a des gens
qui normalement se mobilise de façon
habituelle ce sont les retraités dont
les personnes plutôt âgées ce sont les
diplômés et puis on sait aussi qu'en
revanche est de plus en plus les jeunes
ne se mobilise beaucoup moins se
mobilise beaucoup moins et là on craint
qu'ils se mobilisent très peu et les
personnes moins diplômés et ça c'est un
impact sur les candidats parce que
chaque candidat a évidemment un
électorat particuliers c'est-à-dire
qu'on sait que emmanuel macron à un
électorat de gens plutôt diplômés plutôt
retraités on sait que marine le pen a un
électorat plutôt populaire est un peu
jeune et jean luc mélenchon dont on a
encore peu parler mais qui pourrait
aussi être une surprise de ce second
tour même s'il est pour l'instant loin
derrière les deux premiers mais lui
aussi il essaie de convaincre les
abstentionnistes et notamment les jeunes
que rien n'est plié ce soir mais
justement je voulais que vous me disiez
un mot sur mélenchon parce que ils
montrent aussi le pen monte mais ils
montrent aussi ça serait une surprise si
grant incidences d'une heure et demie
ils seraient au deuxième tour il aurait
il leur est sorti macro envers l'homme
et maquereau le coin ils montrent
pourquoi ils montent mélangeant ils
montent parce que d'abord le surnom
qu'il s'est donné lui-même ces tortues
la tortue saga c'est à dire qu'il est
parti de bart il est parti à 8,9 qui est
pas grand chose et puis il a gagné des
points pourquoi il monte parce qu'il
parle un électorat qui est délaissé qui
l'électorat de gauche et il parle aussi
à la jeunesse lui comme marine le pen a
très vite compris que un des enjeux de
cette de cette campagne c'était le
pouvoir d'achat la difficulté de ivre
d'un certain nombre de français et puis
aujourd'hui il représente
l'alternative alors marine le pen elle
représente l'alternative dans un système
évidemment par rapport à un rapport à
emmanuel macron lui représente
l'alternatif l'alternative de gauche
donc il a fait une campagne lui aussi
très imaginative il l'avait déjà fait en
2017 il a fait une campagne absolument
incroyable du point de vue des nouvelles
technologies on l'a vu en raison au log
ramalho leur grade alors qui en fait le
coup il a fait le coup et ça a bien
fonctionné mais surtout ils parlent
vraiment un électorat qui a elle été
laissée qui est très déçu par emmanuel
macron un électorat de gauche qui
avaient voté maquereau en 2017 et qui
aujourd'hui se sent orphelin de la
gauche on voit des images en direct de
français qui votent donc d'un dea il y a
beaucoup de bureaux de vote il y en a il
y a un match de pro s'il y en a en
amérique du nord non non en france en
france il y en a soit celle où j'ai lu
ce chiffre en france on vous le dira m
c'est pas très grave mais un fric dans
les 33 sociaux 70000 je crois
michel c je veux pas faire de parallèle
boiteux avec les de la difficulté des
partis traditionnels ici mais il reste
que en france la droite traditionnelle
et républicains la gauche traditionnelle
est socialiste je parlais de lambeaux en
introduction là ils se sont liquéfiés
sous nos yeux il ya un bouleversement
total du du jeu politique
oui c'est ça ressemble un peu là où les
deux parties qui sont échangées le
pouvoir au québec on de misère rester
compétitif la même chose est arrivée
écoutez madame pécresse de la droite
héritière du général de gaulle quand
même pas rien va probablement faire
moins de 10 pour ça ce soir et les trois
partis qui étaient de dernièrement du
corps les trois partis de gauche
c'est-à-dire les communistes les
socialistes les écologistes vont
probablement à 1,3 faire moins 10% ce
soir alors il ya un bouleversement
complet d'esprit il ya cinq ans à peine
un jour pour jour il y avait socialiste
qui était président de la république ce
test est monsieur hollande bon il s'est
pas présentée par cerep a été réélu mais
ça sert il était quand même là le parti
socialiste est complètement laminé
pourquoi pourquoi je vous entends
pourquoi cette chute quand même brutale
des socialistes il ya bien des gens qui
disent on n'a pas eu la bonne candidate
c'est la mère de paris madame hidalgo
c'est peut-être pas que madame hidalgo
avait pas le gombo en dix courses c'est
peut-être beaucoup plus que le parti
socialiste plus grand chose à dire on a
vu qu'un tel elle était dans les
entrevues c'était assez banal finalement
et il n'y avait pas d'idée phare du
parti socialiste ou des autres partis et
les communistes ont fait campagne sur la
france des jours heureux bon tout le
monde une bonne heure là se porte
tellement
porteur comme slogan pendant la campagne
électorale alors à un moment donné
d'aller en particulier sur les questions
économiques et sur les questions de
pouvoir d'achat les partis traditionnels
de gauche ont pas été là et monsieur
mélenchon oui lui au moins d'enchaîner
et essayer c'est lui qui est qui a monté
d'ailleurs part à toute cette jungle
mathieu proches
cet effritement des socialistes faut
rappeler une chaîne le disait que oui il
ya cinq ans il y avait un président
socialiste à l'elysée françois hollande
sauf que le candidat qui a représenté le
ps en 2017 qui s'appelait benoît hamon
qui était un candidat de la frange
gauche pendant du parti socialiste a
fait un score qui était aussi famélique
à l'époque c'était un score d'un peu
plus de 6% alors ce lui a permis oui de
rembourser ses frais de campagne mais
c'est un score qui n'est absolument pas
dit effectivement d'un grand parti de
gouvernement qui a été au pouvoir depuis
mitterrand à de nombreuses reprises
jospin ensuite ensuite la présidence
hollande donc ce n'est pas un
effritement qui est soudain ce qui est
effectivement très inquiétant pour le ps
c'est de se retrouver en ce moment
presque dans la marge d'erreur c'est à
dire avec des intentions de vote pour
anne hidalgo qui sont autour de 2% anne
hidalgo la mer on dit maire de paris en
france la mairesse d'une ville dont la
la le mot d'ordre est fluctuat nec
mergitur c'est à dire il poids mais ne
rompt pas finalement ne se noient pas
bien le bateau socialiste dans lequel
elle est embarquée se noie depuis depuis
de nombreux mois depuis qu elle a essayé
d'avoir une candidature d'unités à
gauche elle a échoué à avoir une
candidature d'unités et finalement il ya
encore un éclatement qui fait ressembler
le parti socialiste a trop de chagrin
oui et hélène
le candidat communiste fera mieux
qu'elle ça ne va quand même pas vu ça
mais exactement moi je reviens juste
avant vous vous l'avez dit sur
l'effritement continu de la gauche ce
qui est très nouveau en revanche danser
dans cette élection là c'est
l'effritement attendu de la droite
républicaine les républicains en effet
valérie pécresse la dernière fois encore
françois fillon dont vous souvenez
peut-être qu'il avait été pendant toute
la campagne évidemment empêché par une
histoire de costumes
voilà doursat
et de sa femme effectivement pénélope
peuvent fillon qui avait été accusée d'
emplois fictifs mais n'empêche qu'il
avait terminé le premier tour quand même
autour des 20% or là valérie pécresse
qui est la première femme quand même qui
a été qui est sorti vainqueur d'une
primaire pour la droite républicaine et
donné autour de 10 ou peut-être moins de
10 % ça veut dire aussi que les deux
grands partis de gouvernement en effet
le parti socialiste d'un côté les
républicains qui s'est appelé avant
l'ump qui s'appelait avant le rpr qui
s'appelait avant le rpf du général de
gaulle sont aujourd'hui des partis qui
n'incarne plus les parties gouvernement
et ce serait la deuxième fois de suite
que la droite traditionnelle
républicaine ne ferait pas partie du
deuxième tour et on a dans un monde
nouveau on mange on rentre dans un monde
nouveau d'autant que si la dernière fois
malgré tout on avait mis justement sur
cette difficile campagne le mauvais
score de françois fillon et des
républicains là ce qui s'est passé c'est
que on sent bien que la droite
républicaine
elle est inspirée d'une part par
emmanuel macron et par son projet
centrisme et qui a inspiré un certain
nombre d'électeurs est d'ailleurs d'élus
de la droite républicaine
ayral européenne sans clé il prend
beaucoup de place il prend beaucoup la
sartre et côté droit et côté gauche et
de l'autre côté aspiré savait déjà
commencé avec marine le pen et le
rassemblement national mais avec eric
zemmour qui est arrivé avec son parti
reconquête et qui lui aussi a aspiré un
certain nombre d'électeurs traditionnel
de la droite républicaine on va parler
dans un moment de jeu faisait référence
à ces difficultés de vote à montréal la
consule sera avec nous mais une question
sur valérie pécresse je passe on peut
voir le sondage et l'état à 8 % au
premier tour
il ya eu beaucoup de montage sur les
réseaux sociaux qui ont circulé hélène
le fait qu'elle soit une femme est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un côté encore très macho
dans la politique française qui a fait
que vous allez me dire le pen se faire
mousser mais qui a fait que ça a été
plus dur pour elle à un but et on dira
que c'est pas s'exprimer l'epa nature
est bon est ce que le facteur femme doit
être considérée d'après vous pas je
pense qu'elle peut quand même encore le
prix effectivement d'être une femme
ségolène royal en 2007 qui avait été la
candidate du parti socialiste avait payé
cher aussi le fait d'être une femme
aujourd'hui valérie pécresse avec vous
avez raison les montages qui ont été
faits sur les réseaux sociaux pessah
mais en même temps jean vidic dire sont
par exemple son meeting qu'elle a faits
au zénith était une catastrophe sur la
forme oui et c'est sa femme serait-elle
exactement ici sur le fond et puis sur
le fond quand je dis une catastrophe et
dans le sens rennes n'a pas choisi entre
deux lignes claires et c'est ça aussi
qui a joué et qu'il l'a fait descendre
très bien on verra à combien elle finira
ce premier tour mais disons que sa
carrière comme chef des républicains va
se terminer quelque part cette nuit on
peut imaginer ma fin prêt et lise allard
à montréal bonjour élise dans un
rassemblement des lecteurs à l'union
française alors les gens commencent à
arriver les vitae mais vous allez me
parler diers évidemment des difficultés
relatives mais la difficulté d'aller
voter pour les français
exactement le vote d'hier s'est tenue au
palais des congrès tout près des locaux
de l'union française où je me trouve et
certaines personnes ont dû attendre plus
de trois heures on dit jusqu'à 4 heures
pour aller voter pourtant et bien le
consulat de france de mort à montréal
avait organisé l'événement un peu plus
de façon plus importante la dernière
fois on se rappelle qu'en 2010 est
évalué un ko au collège stanislas donc
on s'attendait qu'avec 15 bureaux de
vote de plus passant de 24 à 39 au
palais des congrès ça allait mal et
beaucoup plus rapidement pour le vote
mais finalement il ya quand même eu des
temps d'attendre certaines personnes ont
attendu moins longtemps par contre ceux
qui sont arrivés plus tard le soir on me
dit que ça a été un petit peu plus un
peu plus rapide mais pour le reste j'ai
eu beaucoup de gens assez déçu de
l'organisation de ce vote à montréal et
je me trouve avec des gens qui ont
travaillé à la campagne de candidat
français candidat à ces élections et qui
ont travaillé vraiment sur le terrain
ici à montréal pour mobiliser les gens
vers certains partis politiques et je
vais commencer par monsieur thibault
frais lige la france insoumise bonjour
ciprelli bonjour alors parlez nous un
peu de ce que vous avez fait pour si on
veut faire campagne pour jean luc
mélenchon ici à montréal évidemment
cette année a été un peu différent des
autres à cause de la kovy donc on a eu
beaucoup d'événements en ligne mon âme
quand même du porte à porte des
événements personne on a pu présenter
notre programme puis aller à la
rencontre des français qui sont nombreux
ici au québec pensez vous que les
français de montréal étaient mobilisés
vers la gauche vers la france est soumis
oui tout à fait c'est le retour du
terrain qu'on avait ici à montréal on
est très contents de de cette
mobilisation qui on pense a été forte à
cette élection présidentielle
de l'autre côté du spectre je me sentais
pas de maison qui lui a retrouvé le goût
en la politique grâce à monsieur eric
zemmour dû partir en conquête à partie
quand on dit d'extrême droite pourquoi
ce pas oui bonjour bon d'extrême droite
non je pense pas mais c'est un parti
patriote effectivement et qui nous a
redonné confiance en la politique ce
qu'on avait perdu du moins moi même ce
que j'avais perdu depuis depuis de
nombreuses années effectivement on a eu
un renouveau également de notre côté
avec avec dvd événement malgré la kovy
donc virtuel au départ après on a fait
des événements en personne et on a vu
effectivement une un renouveau donc
c'est ce qui m'a ce qui m'a séduit dans
ce mouvement qui est à l'autre de
l'autre côté de l'échiquier politique
que la france et insoumise mais parfois
on peut se retrouver aussi au moins 400
personnes qui ont atterri un reconquête
à montréal c'est quand même pas mal oui
c'est exactement ça et en l'espace de
même pas trois mois c'est à dire dès la
création les chiffres ont monté en
flèche donc on a eu beaucoup
d'adhésions et aussi beaucoup de membres
qui se sont impliqués ce que je ne
voyais pas dans les partis traditionnels
que j'ai pu fréquenter durant les vingt
dernières années puisque je suis plus
tout jeune et plus haut ça en trop ça
entre droite suit avec madame chloé
jorat bonjour vous avez fait campagne
pour emmanuel macron vous oui exactement
pendant plusieurs semaines on s'est
mobilisé ici à montréal en tant que
français établis hors de france pour
porter la candidature d'emmanuel macron
et pour expliquer son projet aux
français qui habitent ici à montréal
vous parlez du vote hier 1 termine 1
comment ça s'est passé pour vous c'est
que vous vous avez voté par procuration
exactement j'ai voté par procuration
mais je pense que les français établis
hors de france ici amour elles sont
chanceux parce qu'ils ont eu à leur
disposition 39 bureaux de vote dont il a
eu quelques heures d'attentes en début
d'après midi ça c'est un petit peu
décantée en fin de journée mais je pense
qu'on peut être content et se sentir
chanceux d'avoir eu cette organisation
pour les français ici à montréal mais
vous monsieur vous avez senti quand même
qu'il y avait une certaine est passé à
11 la part de français qui sont venus
voter hier oui bon c'est certain que
comme je le disais on a on a un petit
peu déplacé le problème c'est à dire il
y avait un problème
dans les élections précédentes et au
lieu de régler le problème on a dépassé
au palais des congrès et finalement on a
eu une sorte de on a eu plus de bureaux
de vote c'est vrai mais d'un autre côté
quand vous faisait quand vous faites une
compression à un moment donné bon bah
c'est certain que vous avez une file
d'attenté monstrueuses
donc en fait on a discuté un petit peu
entre nous on s'est dit déjà il faudrait
certainement faire plusieurs lieux mais
ce qui entraînerait d'autres problèmes
éventuellement mais également dans les
dents les dans ces lieux avoir plus
d'entrée parce que lie avec une seule
entrée donc j'ai certain que ça qu'on
pressent finalement ou en terminant
beaucoup ont critiqué
l'accueil le processus d'introduction si
on veut assez ce vote à ce scrutin à
montréal donc ce serait peut-être une
question à poser à la consule générale
de france madame sophie la gauche un peu
plus tard à l'émission et j'aimerais
terminer en vous disant que la
population française à montréal a
augmenté de façon assez importante en
cinq ans depuis les dernières élections
on parle de 10 mais les lecteurs de plus
on n'est pas assez de 55 mille électeurs
inscrits à 67000 en cinq ans seulement
donc on peut comprendre que c'est tout
un trac hot une organisation à mettre en
place pour accueillir des gens on va de
plusieurs dizaines de minutes français
qui sont venus voter hier dans la
métropole cent quarante mille français
au québec 81 mille électeurs inscrits à
montréal c'est 65 mille électeurs
inscrits 120 milles on n'a qu'à se
promener d'ailleurs dans les rues de
montréal pour voir que que oui il ya
beaucoup de français mathieu presse vous
souriez confié
sophie lagoutte consul général de france
à montréal est avec nous je crois même
la goutte bonjour
bonjour monsieur alors on pourrait se
dire
elle est pas bon on s'attendait
peut-être pas autant mais là vous saviez
qui allait avoir quand même beaucoup de
gens qu'elle vouloir voter que c'est
c'est le passé est-ce que vous avez été
un peu dépassés ou quoi
depuis 2007 on avait beaucoup étoffé le
dispositif tout d'abord en passant au
palais des congrès qui est un lieu apte
à recevoir
les événements vraiment d'ampleur nous
avions également augmenté le nombre de
bureaux de vote on est dépassé de 20 ans
tu neuf bureaux de vote est réellement à
l'étranger nous posons beaucoup sur des
bénévoles également pour accompagner les
électeurs nous avions multiplié par
quatre le nombre de bénévoles pour tout
au long de la journée donc on avait un
dispositif qui était très développée par
rapport à 2010 est et il y a eu cette
année un très fort engouement non ce qui
est une bonne nouvelle pour notre
démocratie avec une fréquentation qui a
été très concentré dans la journée
puisque à partir de 15 ou 16 heures les
fils ont beaucoup diminué à 17 heures il
n'y avait plus aucune attente mais il
est vrai que les électeurs qui sont
venus en milieu de journée
devait faire des queues impressionnante
pour pour rentrer ça a été un vrai défi
mais tout le monde a pu voter et a pu
participer au scrutin sans difficulté
jusqu'à la fin de la journée ouais enfin
quelques genres ont rebroussé chemin on
a eu quelques nouvelles parce que
c'était trop long qu'ils avaient des
choses à faire mais est ce que pour le
cc le passé hier est ce que vous allez
vous ajustez pour le deuxième tour
bien sûr on fait toujours un retour
d'expérience après un scrutin est une
échéance aussi importante que telle
fille donc oui il y aura des ajustements
il s'agissait pour nous d'un nouveau
lieu c'est première fois que nous
organisions des élections au palais des
congrès il ya naturellement des leçons à
tirer pour que le deuxième tour soit
plus fluide et pour faciliter encore la
participation démocratique des français
de l'étranger à montréal donc
davantage de bénévoles si possible
d'abord parce que le palais des congrès
en principe il ya beaucoup de monde on
peut faire rouler beaucoup de gens en
peu de temps
c'est tout à fait la raison pour
laquelle nous avons choisi ce lieu qui
est tout à fait adapté et effectivement
l'objectif est de permettre d'accueillir
très rapidement beaucoup d'électeurs
pour faire des salles à participation
citoyenne madame la gaude consul le
général de la france à montréal merci de
nous avoir parlé
merci beaucoup bonne journée bonne
journée à vous de vote mathieu on
parlait de cette déconstruction
des partis traditionnels en france la
droite c'est important il ya des choses
à préciser bousculés à l'extrême et ça a
commencé en fait dès la primaire
chez les républicains des républicains
s'est de nouveau donc partis dominants
de droite qui a eu lieu à la fin de
l'année dernière on pressentait xavier
bertrand qui l'aurait emporté finalement
ça s'est joué à l'extrême avec eric
ciotti qui est arrivé deuxième face à
valérie pécresse et donc valérie
pécresse a été un peu prise par ce score
d'eric ciotti pour intégrer des éléments
à son programme les électeurs
traditionnels de droite ne l'ont pas
suivi à la dévissé dans les sondages
vous savez il ya eu quelque chose d'un
peu anecdotique mais lors de la primaire
il ya un chien qui a voté qui a voté
pour le chien qui a voté pour valérie
pécresse donc il ya eu quand même comme
ça des des espèces de petites anecdotes
un peu un peu spéciale pendant cette
primaire la campagne je le disais de
valérie pécresse elle à dévisser
complètement au point qu'aujourd'hui je
vous remonte cette courbe ça c'est la
courbe de 2017 elle fait moins bien
hélène le disait elle fait moyens moins
bien que françois fillon qui était
empêtré dans plusieurs affaires il a
terminé à 20% elle en ce moment à
valérie pécresse est derrière eric
zemmour dans les estimations parce qu'il
y à ce phénomène là effectivement dont
il faut parler eric zemmour qui s'est
déclarée donc candidat à la
présidentielle dans cette vidéo qui l'a
diffusée sur youtube qui a été obligé
d'être retirée de youtube pourquoi parce
qu'il a été condamné pour violation de
droits d'auteur il a aussi été condamné
pour provocation à la haine raciale
pendant cette campagne eric zemmour il a
fait appel c'est un programme eric
zemmour qui est axé beaucoup beaucoup
sur l'immigration sur la sécurité il
veut créer un ministère de l'arrêt
migration qui est lié à ses thèses ces
thèses d'extrême droite sur le grand
remplacement alors évidemment il
bouscule les cartes et ils jouent ils
jouent exactement dans les terres de
marine le pen est ailleurs c'est ce qui
s'est passé depuis quelques mois c'est à
dire que le visage plus du d'eric
zemmour avec ses thèmes martelé sur
l'immigration sur le retour des
étrangers chez eux fait passer marine le
pen pour quelqu'un de beaucoup plus doué
qui a su se saisir en temps opportun des
début février avant même la guerre en
ukraine avant même l'augmentation du
prix des carburants etc a su se saisir
du thème du thème du pouvoir d'achat
essayer de fédérer autour d'elle
évidemment tous les mécontents qui
remonte jusqu'au gilet jaune pour
retrouver la france telle qu'elle était
telle qu'elle devait être il il va même
et madame le pen ne va pas aussi loin
hélène à dire moi je vais interdire les
prénoms étrangers ce que tu ne viens
viens une loi qui a existé qui avait été
abrogée mais bref zemmour pour
l'immigration est allé à fond ce qui a
fait paraître madame le pen plus docile
c'est à dire qu'il a fait une campagne
monothématique sur l'immigration en en
se saisissant en effet de cette théorie
raciste et complotistes qui est celle du
grand remplacement
il a réussi quand même dans un premier
temps à imposer ses thèmes de campagne
souvenez vous de cet automne on ne
parlait que d'eric zemmour et que
d'immigration et puis d'ailleurs il ya
un certain nombre de soutiens
historiques de marine le pen qui ont
quitté marine le pen à ce moment là pour
rejoindre et eric zemmour qui était
plutôt en ascension jusqu'à la nièce de
marine le pen marion maréchal marion
maréchal-le pen qui a rejoint eric
zemmour ça c'est la première partie de
campagne et puis ce qui est venu
percuter on l'a déjà de vue dit cette
campagne c'est en effet la guerre en
ukraine qui a quand même tout changer et
là
eric zemmour qui avait quand même des
amitiés des passions
coupable pour vladimir poutine qu'il
admirait complètement a quand même été
très dérangés par cette par cette
intervention là dans la campagne il a
fait preuve également d'inhumanité en
décidant que les ukrainiens les réfugiés
ukrainiens n'avaient pas leur place en
france alors que marine le pen elle a
compris que dans le coeur des français
c'était possible de dire on voyait des
images monstrueuse d'enfants de femmes
bombardé c'était possible de dire oui
nous pouvons les accueillir chez nous il
ne s'est pas rendu compte que le grand
remplacement finalement été remplacé
dans cette campagne par la peur du
grande des classements et elle l a
compris ça et elle a récupéré dans on
l'a dit les dernières semaines de
campagne
et puis vous avez raison il ya eu un
effet complètement lui dure inhumain et
elle
la maman avec ses chars on a beaucoup vu
ses chats sur les réseaux sociaux tout à
coup elle a totalement changé d'image ou
et sur les ukrainiens et moore quand
même c'est une gaffe majeure et même
dans son camp on ne savait pas trop
comment reculer parce que c'était faire
ce faire nous montrer une inhumanité
incroyable que le dire on veut pas les
accueillir c'est ma logique je reste
cartésien je veux pas de migrants qui
souhaitent craignais que toi africain je
n'en veux pas celle-là couler mais ce
qui est étrange fait référence à ça
c'est que ce son admiration pour poutine
parce que zemmour le dit souvent qu'il
admirait le côté nationaliste de poutine
qui est qui travaille pour sa nation
semble avoir ralenti et marine le pen
qui est allé en campagne à 2017 au
kremlin lui elle ça ne l'a pas fait
chuter pourquoi rapidement presque
mathieu et michel mais parce que elle
elle avait tout de suite compris qu'il
fallait faire campagne sur autre chose
lui il n'avait rien d'autre à proposer
que son grand remplacement donc elle
mais ça le set cette admiration pour
poutine elle est également partagé quand
même par jean luc mélenchon à l'extrême
gauche est lui ça l'a un peu plus
dérangé mais marine le pen elle a réussi
à faire oublier quasiment même si quand
même y en a quelques-uns qui s'en sont
souvenus et je pense que dans la queue
dans une campagne de second tour si elle
est au second tour ce soir contre
emmanuel macron ce que nous ne savons
pas encore ce thème là malgré tout
géopolitique de positionnement par
rapport aux deux grandes alliances va
lui être posées et pourrait redevenir
peut-être un problème pour l échelle
c'est sur cette question de poutine
comment ça a plombé quand même la
campagne de zemmour ses déclarations sur
sur les sur les réfugiés ukrainien entre
autres son admiration pour poutine le
côté nationaliste a salué en lui
beaucoup
salut est venu beaucoup il pouvait pas
prévoir vous me direz que
il y allait avoir une guerre nucléaire
en pleine campagne électorale mais quand
même mais pour madame le pen aussi un
problème poutine au tout début de la
campagne avait été obligé d'envoyer au
pilon un peu plus que millions de
dépliants où elle avait une belle photo
d'elle avec monsieur poutine qui avait
été prise la dernière fois qu'elle était
allée à moscou où elle a été reçue
quasiment comme un chef d'état sa
dernière campagne électorale elle doit
toujours des sous à une banque russe qui
kills la finance oui et alors ça ça pas
beaucoup sortis on a beaucoup sorti la
question de l'ukraine et de poutine pour
zemmour on en a pas beaucoup parlé pour
madame le pen c'est assez évident que si
elle est au deuxième tour c'est une des
choses dont on va parler de la même
façon que la dernière élection elle
s'était fait vraiment ramassés par macro
en débat sur la question quitté l'union
européenne
là elle ne veut plus quitter l'union
européenne mais elle veut remettre les
frontières de la france donc c'est celle
à la libre circulation des biens des
personnes dont elle veut sortir et d'un
certain nombre de traités qui font que
l'europe et l'europe alors ça aussi ça
va revenir dans le temps dans le débat
du deuxième tour si elle y est ma corps
commencé à le faire au cours des
derniers jours mais bon
il n'y a pas fait qu'un prix très
longtemps pour ce premier tour c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire parlez moi
hélène et michel de ceux de se combattre
le courant nationaliste de côté le
courant plus mondialistes comme l' aime
l'appeler l'ailé les nationalismes
européens de l'autre ça joue la donne ça
fait partie des lignes de force de cette
campagne hélène
ça fait partie de ce qui est de diviser
mais en même temps d'abord c'est ce que
voulait emmanuel macron
en 2010 est déjà pour se faire élire il
faisait le clivage gauche droite ça
n'existe plus ce qui nous sépare
aujourd'hui c'est deux façons
effectivement de se positionner dans le
monde de regarder l'histoire il y a les
nationalistes et puis il y aller
comment comment les appeler les
européens les les libéraux
les mondialistes même si je pense que
c'est un peu trop noté voilà mais encore
une fois là ce qui est venu percuter
cette campagne mais je crois comme
michel que
ça va se passer différemment pour le
second tour c'est qu'on a un peu oublié
cette fracture là c'est à dire on voit
bien que c'est ce qui fracturent le
monde politique le paysage politique
français mais les électeurs ne se sont
pas tellement positionner sur sept
sur sept fractures là encore une fois
ils se sont positionnés sur leur vie à
eux et leur vie à eux aujourd'hui c'est
les difficultés de vivre l'inflation le
pouvoir d'achat l'énergie qui augmente
et c'est ça qui semble-t-il a quand même
fait monter dans ces derniers jours
notamment marine le pen mais aussi d'une
certaine façon
jean luc mélenchon mêlant chant michel
là les choses très concrètes comme
disait un conseiller américain 10
grammes et si tu auprès de la ce qui
touche les gens
ça reste important à chaque élection
un autre verrou pour le tex lecor
c'est vraiment ça c'est des enjeux
locaux qui ont bon c'est de ça la
grandeur de la france les prix de
l'énergie mais c'est des enjeux sont pas
les grands enjeux de la mondialisation
ou des choses comme ça et monsieur
macron avait l'air justement de le coter
jupitérien là moi je moi je m'occupe de
ce qui se passe dans le monde l'appelle
pouls de synge j'essaie de voir ce que
je peux faire pour régler la guerre en
ukraine alors que les gens disaient non
moi c'est mon compte de gasques avec
lequel j'ai un problème là alors là il
faudra voir ce qui va se passer parce
qu'il ya quand même eu
traditionnellement un front anti extrême
droite s'est formé quand monsieur le pen
père avait été candidat en 2002 et à la
dernière élection le seul problème pour
monsieur mâcon lasker il est le
président sortant il a été attaqué par
tous les autres candidats c'est bien
normal au cours de cette campagne là
c'est beaucoup plus difficile d'avoir
passé deux mois à dire macron est pas
très bon macro nettoyer pas très fort et
après ça nous aimons voir où on vous on
veut arrêter l'extrême droite on peut
vous dire de voter macro ça va être un
petit peu difficile pour les candidats
qui devront se retirer ce soir de faire
ce genre de gymnastique je rappelle aux
gens que c'est à 14h notre heures qu'on
aura le score et que si ça se confirme
qu'on croit qu'il va arriver macron le
pen ça sera pile c'est assez rare
ce sera un gros match nous on en a
souvent dans la politique canadienne
québécoise des matchs revanche je vais
ce sera un match revanche mais comme dit
michel la différence est que macro et un
bilan cette fois ci à défendre ce qui
n'était pas le cas la dernière fois
était tout nouveau il y arrivait d'avec
son nouveau mouvement dernier match
revanche j'avais été
mitterrand jusqu'à d'estaing mitterrand
battu la première fois et gagne la
deuxième fois mais il y en a pas eu
d'autre dans l'histoire de vaud jeudi de
vaud de la politique françois hollande
on l'a dit tout à l'heure mais avait
décidé de ne pas être candidat à sa
propre succession donc
donc il faut maintenant je reviens pas
eu il y aurait pu en avoir on le saura
jamais mathieu preuve on a dit que la
gauche était atomisé en tout cas la
gauche plus radicalement de la gauche
traditionnelle
est au plancher ce changement du paysage
politique français effectivement c'est
d'abord le parti socialiste qui en fait
les frais ce parti socialiste donc
souteyrand puis ensuite jospin puis
hollande je vais vous montrer les
dernières compositions de l'assemblée
nationale pour voir l'ampleur du chemin
envoyé en rose mais c'est la gauche
dominée par le parti socialiste en droit
en bleu ça c'était l'ump en 2007 sous
sarkozy du voyez à quel point ils
dominaient la chambre à l'assemblée
nationale 2012 françois hollande prend
le pouvoir les socialistes encore en
très bonne position l'ump réduit un peu
voici ce qu'a créé emmanuel macron en
2017 la vague de la république en marche
et vous voyez à quel point la droite
républicaine et la gauche emmenée par
les socialistes est réduite à peau de
chagrin et c'est pourtant dans ce petit
espace ici que les candidatures se sont
multipliés à cette année il y à cette
candidature de gauche et c'est ce qui
avait contribué cette multiplication des
candidatures à ceux ci en 2002 ce qu'on
a qualifié du séisme politique
l'accession de jean-marie le pen au
deuxième tour de la présidentielle face
à jacques chirac s'était donc il y a
vingt ans multiplication des
candidatures à gauche haute abstention
record on l'a dit plus de 28% alors il
ya pour éviter ça il ya des citoyens qui
ont essayé d'organiser une primaire à
gauche une primaire populaire mais ils
ont un peu embrigader de forces des
candidats dedans puisque jean luc
mélenchon anne hidalgo par exemple avait
dit qu'il ne voulait pas y participer
tant mieux puisqu'ils n'ont pas gagné
c'est christiane taubira qui a gagné
sauf quand on parlait d'une drôle de
campagne christiane taubira a été obligé
de jeter l'épongé
finalement parce qu'elle n'a pas eu les
parrainages nécessaires et finalement
elle appuie jean luc mélenchon donc il
ya déjà une consigne de vote pour ce
premier tour vous voyez tous les
candidats
gauche ici parce que selon christiane
taubira et beaucoup jean luc mélenchon
serait le seul selon la dynamique
actuelle à pouvoir capitaliser sur du
vote de gauche l'ancien vote socialiste
et pouvoir être le seul en mesure
d'accéder au second tour c'est la
dynamique qui anime sa campagne depuis
les dernières semaines c'est ce qui fait
qu'il y a ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
vote utile ou un vote efficace sur sa
candidature pour peut-être passer devant
marine le pen accéder au second tour ce
serait effectivement la grosse surprise
de cette de cette soirée où et du méga
mais on n'est pas l'abri de surprises
mais effectivement mélenchon serait le
seul troisième joueur à pouvoir se
faufiler on va parler de la gauche qui
ne ressemble plus à la gauche
traditionnelle
on retrouve adrien matou vous êtes
journaliste politique pour le magazine
marianne vous êtes auteur du livre la
mélenchon la chute comment la france
insoumise s'est effondré il est en
direct vous êtes en direct du
rassemblement de monsieur mélenchon à
paris bonjour monsieur matte ou
alors expliqué expliquez-nous on a déjà
commencé à le faire mais ce qui est
arrivé à la gauche traditionnelle
pourquoi le parti socialiste ne sais
même pas s'ils seront remboursés s'ils
auront le 5 % qui est le seuil pour être
remboursé rembourser les dépenses
électorales car même quelque chose
alors c'est une trajectoire qui a écrit
plusieurs paliers dans la ville et là il
a beaucoup aidé mais moi je retiendrai
deux coups d'abord le parti socialiste
quand il était au pouvoir avant que déçu
avec toi gauche économique et social en
milieu politique et les parents au
libéral
et
c'est parti je dirais que sur les thèmes
identitaires sur les scènes culturelles
et bien à gauche a abandonné
historique vous connaissez ici au canada
comme la laïcité et je pense en effet
que manière de se détourner de son nez
sa tradition de laïcité a aussi en
partie technique et les classes
populaires et aujourd'hui on voit que
les classes populaires à la
présidentielle
votre un petit plus dans les planches ou
pas du tout pour les autres en
guadeloupe donc la question de la
laïcité comme vous dites la question
même de l'immigration la question
beaucoup de gens dans les classes
populaires or paris lors centre de paris
se disent les socialistes entre autres
sont totalement déconnectés quoi
la gauche en france incarne pour
beaucoup de gens n'ont plus de gens une
espèce de sociologie très urbaine très
bourgeoise et repliée sur les centres
villes et elle paraît un petit peu
déconnecté des préoccupations furent
nombreux et c'est pour ça qu'il est
triple non seulement la gauche était
faible résultat mais on pousse on à
marine le pen qui est si haut et qui a
priori est bien parti pour se qualifier
pour le second tour que fera mais là un
champ si c'est comme on croit macron le
pen au deuxième tour
qu'est ce que vous pensez que mélenchon
va faire cette fois ci la dernière fois
il n'avait pas dit pour qui voter
j'ai pas évidemment l'information en
exclusivité mais je pense qu'il devrait
faire comme l'année la fois tout
simplement parce que d'une part les
consignes de vote apparaissent comme
dépassée pour beaucoup de gens mais plus
du tout dans cette équipe type ou aux
responsables politiques de dire à son
électorat au petit goûter et en plus
jean luc mélenchon il incarne une espèce
de refus parce que je décrivais un petit
peu avant et donc en réalité pour lui ce
serait un peu se conformer aux systèmes
de voter d'alerté directement pour mac
ou à mon avis il ya beaucoup d'électeurs
de joindre ou encore plus qu'en 2017 qui
ne sont pas de grande différence entre
les gagnants de makli et marine le pen
et je pense que je ne parle pas des
brutes il me wade et décevoir en
appelant clairement
une petite dernière avant de vous
laisser à l'évolution est un peu
difficile mais je vais quand même vous
poser une petite dernière mélenchon est
ce que c'est sa dernière campagne vous
croyez où il sera là tant qu'il pourra
il a promis que ce serait sa dernière
je pense que sa teneur présidentielle on
se calme ce qui le rend optimiste c'est
un grand admirateur de françois
mitterrand et que françois mitterrand a
gagné la présidentielle à se croiser
décès reste à savoir si ça va
je ris mais il ne faut plus rire de
l'improbable improbable arrivants
politique de plus en plus merci merci
beaucoup merci à vous merci monsieur
matou qui a écrit un livre sur le
phénomène
mélenchon alors michel c'est que vous
êtes à paris
mélenchon c'est un personnage et les il
est très bon dans les mitaines il est
très bon dans les interviews il à la
dube à google
il ya du bon goût il a aussi du contenu
et c'est ça c'est la jonction des deux
qui fait que c'est intéressant de voir
un entrevue ou encore mieux un discours
de
mélenchon sait que lui dit voici nos
solutions puis voici le problème auquel
ça pourrait s'intéresser et voici
pourquoi ils le font pas et voici
pourquoi ils ne font pas mention des
intérêts s'ils ont des intérêts là mais
c'est très pédagogique et en même temps
à vos france elle n'est pas plate alors
le débat avec zemmour avait été quelque
chose oui oui mais même un meeting de
ménage au sans compter tout il y en a
même fait un odorat mahoto au tout début
de la campagne je sais pas si ça a
marché très fort mais
ça attire déjà bien sûr mais il donne il
donne vraiment un bon spectacle et c'est
aussi très pédagogique a lancé c'est une
force pour un candidat c'est sur ça et
l'inde si ils quittent puis il dit ce
qu'il le fait est-ce que ce mouvement-là
peut être pris oui ils n'ont pas il
meurt mais s'efface avec lui il est
porteur c'est lui qui a créé la france
est soumise en quittant le parti
socialiste puisque ça a été très
longtemps un militant un élu et même un
ministre avec le parti socialiste sous
lionel jospin
moi je vais revenir juste d'un mot sur
l'histoire du de sa consigne ou pas
consignes de molex aux soirées du report
des voix la dernière fois il avait dit
pas de consigne de vote mais pas une
voix pour l'extrême droite il ya
quelques jours l'entourage de des
manuels macron disait on craint qu'ils
ne fassent pire ça veut dire quoi pire
là quand même la dernière fois il avait
dit pas une voix pour l'extrême droite
donc on était capable de comprendre en
gros il fallait pas voter marine le pen
là il pourrait ne même pas aller jusque
là c'est à dire dire blanc bonnet et
bonnet blanc c'est à dire faites ce que
vous voulez parce que finalement les
deux se valent et ça ce serait une
mauvaise nouvelle évidemment pour une
médiation entre caution pour madame le
pen prévues comme son passage amène
évidemment mais voilà il ya aucun mot
aucune propension aucune velléité de
jean-luc mélenchon à soutenir marine le
pen c'est pas ça le propos on a vu quand
même dans les dernières dans les
dernières enquêtes d'opinion qui avait
pas loin de 30 % des électeurs du
premier tour de jean luc mélenchon qui
étaient prêts à voter marine le pen au
second tour alors à peu près dans la
même proportion ils votent emmanuel
macron mais 30 % quand même ça veut dire
que malgré tout il est porteur d'un
électorat très anti macron et que celui
ci peut se reporter d'une certaine façon
au second tour pour marine le pen ou ne
pas aller voter ce qui évidemment pour
emmanuel macron par défaut et est aussi
un grand risque mais on aura le temps
d'en parler il ya vraiment une nouvelle
campagne qui démarre dès 14 heures enfin
20h heure de paris c'est deuxième tour
il ya un autre nos dynamiques qui reste
totalement une autre dynamique et c'est
pas parceque ils sont au coude à coude
là qu'ils le seront nécessairement
deuxième tour on verra mathieu s'est
historiquement
il ya nos dynamiques et
s'il faut aller chercher les votes qu'on
n'a pas obtenu effectivement au premier
tour pour essayer d'aller et bien
franchir cette barre des 1 des 50% donc
on ajuste son discours à ce moment là on
va parler à des électeurs à qui on n'a
pas parlé pendant la campagne du premier
tour un mot quand même sur sur la
personnalité
de jean luc mélenchon qui a changé quand
même entre la dernière campagne et celle
ci s'est beaucoup assagi il le disait
lui-même d'ailleurs dernièrement il dit
je me suis pris la tête entre guillemets
avec personne notre en personne à gauche
parce qu'il était effectivement à
couteaux tirés avec les communistes
pendant très longtemps il a beaucoup dit
beaucoup beaucoup de mal sur son
ancienne famille socialiste est là il
est resté effectivement beaucoup en
retrait là dessus est aussi beaucoup
moins virulent avec les journalistes
parce que il a été très véhément avec la
presse alors c'est un jean luc mélenchon
qui s'est beaucoup adouci vous êtes
effectivement aussi comme comme marine
le pen qui était qui était plus douce et
ce que dit ce que dit hélène est vrai
effectivement les électorats à un
certain point des deux extrêmes se
retrouvent parce qu'il y avait
effectivement certaines convergences
parfois dans le même temps ce qu'on va
chercher comme colère auprès des
catégories les plus les plus populaires
bien certains électeurs de marine le pen
peuvent se retrouver chez jean que
mélenchon et inversement ce qui peut
effectivement brouiller les cartes pour
une dynamique de second tour oui et
l'aimer mais les temps ont changé aussi
les appels de vote pour le deuxième tour
c'est pas comme des brebis qui écoute le
le grand chef puis quand on va dans
cette direction là les gens ont quand
même une autonomie puis dépendantes la
ville complexe là on est en plein
travail heures on peut en même temps oui
avoir une déclinaison plus à gauche mais
pour certaines histoires plus à droite
bref c'est pas si simple que ça non on
s'en doute les consignes de vote n'ont
plus du tout le même poids dans qu'elle
pouvait y avoir il ya 20 ou 30 ans mais
ça dit quelque chose forcément
d'abord du leader qui va poser ou pas
cette consigne et puis aussi du de ce
qui va se passer on parlait pendant très
longtemps pendant très longtemps il ya
un front républicain contre l'extrême
droite jean marie le pen en 2002
lorsqu'il se qualifie contre jacques
chirac
ça a encore marché la dernière fois mais
les scores vous voyez jean marie le pen
il perd en 2002 contre jacques chirac on
est à 82,18 s'est fait massacrer d'abord
il n'y a pas de débat de
l'entre-deux-tours à l'époque jacques
chirac refuse d'aller débattre avec jean
marie le pen
et puis toute la gauche toute la droite
républicaine ce mobilisme sursaut il ya
un sursaut 2017 ça fonctionne encore
emmanuel macron et quand même élu avec
66% des voix quand marine le pen contre
marine le pen là qu'est ce qui va se
passer valérie pécresse vous l'avez dit
d'un mot tout à l'heure a déjà dit que l
dire est ce qu elle allait voter mais
qu'elle ne donnerait pas de consigne de
vote françois fillon la dernière fois
avait donné une consigne de vote avait
dit un jour vote emmanuel macron et je
vous appelle à éviter le pire et à voter
macron vous avez raison aujourd'hui un
électeur n'a pas forcément besoin de
quelqu'un pour lui dire ce qu'il doit
voter ça dit quelque chose malgré tout
d'abord de ce qui peut se passer ou pas
se passer au second tour et puis de la
façon dont chaque famille politique va
se recomposer derrière parlez-moi de
zemmour est ce que lui dira clairement
parce que ils ont été lui a été très
dure avec madame le pen en campagne dans
la sq mais lui dira clairement voté
madame le pen il la déteste vraiment
mais je pense qu'il pourra pas faire
autrement
c'est cohérent ça serait con et bien sûr
leur électorat malgré tout et le même
beaucoup plus diplômés l'électorat de
d'eric zemmour c'est pas l'électorat de
marine le pen il est allé chercher de
nouveaux électeurs d'extrême droite
évidemment mais j'ai envie de dire leur
programme il est le même un peu caché
masqué pour marine le pen pour arriver
au niveau où elle en est aujourd'hui
mais c'est le même donc je pense que ce
soir ce sera très compliqué pour y
ériger âge
bouvier au clair on vous retrouve à
paris en direct du rassemblement des
manuels macron est-ce qu'il ya davantage
de monde d'abord est-ce que qu'est-ce
que comment vous pouvez me décrire
l'atmosphère
va écouter ça commence à arriver après
tout on attend ses premières estimations
de résultats dans les 30 prochaines
minutes donc là quand même des bénévoles
des méditants également du président
sortant qui arrive dans la salle sont
quand même plusieurs centaines de ce que
je vois en ce moment difficile d'estimer
à combien en tout cas il ya beaucoup de
médias ont indiqué des centaines et des
centaines de journalistes qui sont ici
on verra s'il y aura autant de militants
mais ça arrive les gens se font
distribuer des drapeaux de la france
drapeau de l'union européenne évidemment
on connaît l'attachement des manuels
macro et de ses partisans l'union
européenne donc ça arrive ce que me
disait un des bénévoles à qui j'ai parlé
à quelques minutes c'est que clairement
par contre l'énergie l'atmosphère est
bien différente de celle d'il ya cinq
ans 2007 quand emmanuel macron
finalement avait en quelque sorte créé
la surprise lors de cette élection
présidentielle là aujourd'hui évidemment
le contexte n'est pas le même il faut
défendre un bilan et on la constate me
disais c'est ce bénévole cette remontée
de marine le pen dans dans les sondages
alors déjà on est en train de penser ici
au sein des troupes ma cronista la
stratégie à adopter pour pour le
deuxième tour de l'élite
le décès est effectivement au 2e tour
que tout va se jouer à moins du méga
surprise qui de ceux qui n'arrivent pas
et que l'on disait tout à l'heure la
seule hypothèse et mélenchon les
sondages est vraiment mal vu tout ça et
qu'ils soient qui se retrouve au
deuxième tour avec le pen mais là ce
serait la débandade totale mais sinon on
va le voir plus dans les deux prochaines
semaines il y aura débat leur affaire
assez clair et le débat en 2017 avait
été un moment fort de la campagne d'
emmanuel macron se débat contre marine
le pen alors il y aura possiblement on
le saura dans une trentaine de minutes
un match revanche cette année entre
monsieur macro et marine le pen mais
clairement il faut s'attendre à une
présence plus grande des manuels m'a
trop sur le terrain au cours des
prochaines semaines parce qu'il est
entré on en a parlé tout à l'heure à
l'émission il est entré très tardivement
dans cette campagne avec un grand
rassemblement qui a finalement été le
seul à peu près une semaine du premier
tour de l'élection et pendant que
emmanuel macron voyait sa cote de
popularité est 6è plus baisser dans les
sondages marine le pen elle monte
tranquillement on l'a constaté dans ses
équipes et en contre l'ancien premier
ministre d'emmanuel macro edouard
philippe piat constater qu'il a dit
c'est tout à fait possible que marine le
pen puisse l'emporter alors clairement
on va travailler à cette stratégie et
d'ailleurs on entende de plus en plus on
le voit sur les réseaux sociaux on
entend de la bouche de partisans du
président des attaques directes à
l'endroit de marine le pen alors que
c'était peut-être un peu moins clair au
cours des dernières semaines quand on se
concentraient surtout sur la stature
présidentielle déménageront le chef
d'état qui était très impliqué dans le
le conflit entre l'ukraine et la russie
mais c'est une belle morale que
personne ne peut faire l'économie d'une
campagne
peu importe le contexte international
merci beaucoup on se retrouve tout à
l'heure à nyc béraud une campagne de
cinq ans une campagne ça compte tout à
fait annick rebonjour et au
rassemblement je rappelle de marine le
pen par bon vous êtes à l'intérieur là
j'imagine qu'on a bien entre ses dents
je le rappelle mesdames et messieurs
c'est dans moins d'une demi-heure à 14h
notre heures qu'on aura les résultats
donc de ce premier tour j'imagine qu'à
delà de la nervosité
mais aussi de la fébrilité beaucoup de
confiance c'est ce que m'ont dit des
militants qui ont commencé à arriver
dans la dernière demi-heure renvoyer
peut-être derrière moi il ya surtout
devant moi vous mettre dans la
confidence ya des tables avec des petits
fours et du champagne qui coule déjà
appelons donc confiance mais en même
temps les études par rapport à
l'abstention à qui est ce que ça va
nuire ce taux d'abstention là c'est la
grande interrogation mais confiant quand
même confiant de voir marine le pen
accéder au second tour et vous savez le
moddeur bon me rappelle parlait des
attaques qui commençait déjà de la part
des macros nist du camp du président
sortant et candidat manuel macro qui est
déjà le mot d'ordre ici d'un auprès des
troupes du rassemblement national c'est
de rester calmes de d'avoir un
comportement exemplaire parce que les
attaques elles vont fuser et elles
fusent déjà parce que si on regarde sur
les comptes twitter des lieutenants
elles mêmes
emmanuel macron vous faites le mot-clic
marine poutine alors on souligne olivier
de marine le pen elle a pas trop parlé à
du président russe mais elle avait
rencontré officiellement en 2010 cette
annonce à savoir revenir à la surface
plus en plus avec plus de 10 ans d mais
voilà exactement la seule vue des
rencontres informelles avant mais
vraiment dur à la campagne 2010 est une
photo officielle cette photo mc avaient
commencé à circuler d'ailleurs dans les
dépliants de campagne avant la guerre en
ukraine s'est distanciée si rapidement
marine le pen de vladimir poutine en
tout cas ne parle pas beaucoup aux indes
et rassemblant au total il y avait sur
des écrans géants on la voyait vous
savez on est devenu une posture
internationale on le voyait avec des
photos avec salvini de l'italie mais
elle rien le blazy maire poutine on sent
que ça va être peut-être le talon
d'achille de marine le pen durera un
entre-deux tours si jamais elle est une
des finalistes le court le deuxième tour
dans une quinzaine de joueurs et c'est
clair que et pendant que les horreurs
dans l'est ukrainien je poursuis
évidemment que le camp macron va vouloir
lui mettre ça dans la figure à chaque
jour merci année qu'à tout de suite on
se reparle tout de suite après les
résultats à 14 heures hélène est ce que
c'est les français qui sont davantage
disposés à des programmes plus
extrémistes ou cl madame le pen qui a
changé le programme pour le mettre au
niveau du goût des français on ne va pas
changer son programme elle a masqué son
programme ce qui est assez différente
c'est à dire que l a effectivement
habilement senti que la thématique du
pouvoir d'achat de l'inflation des fans
mois difficiles monthey et donc c'est
parfait et d'ailleurs elle avait déjà
apporté un certain nombre de de réponse
à ça mais par ailleurs elle n'a pas
changé son programme son programme c'est
toujours quand elle arrive à l'elysée
dit m j'ai un projet de loi immigration
qui est prêt il sera proposé par
référendum aux français et c'est un
projet de loi qui restreint de façon
évidemment jamais vu en france un
certain nombre de droits pour les
étrangers installés en france elle ne
dit plus qu'elle veut sortir de l'europe
n'est qu'elle veut sortir de l'euro mais
en réalité ce qu'elle propose va aboutir
exactement à la même chose puisqu'elle
veut dénoncer un certain nombre de
traités européens qui de fait mettrait
la france en situation de manquement
donc façon on n'aurait pas d'autre choix
que d'être sortie de l'europe si son
programme était donc l son programme n'a
pas changé ce qui est sûr c'est que
la façon dont aujourd'hui les
l'électorat peut se réfugier dans un
vote que nous on peut juger ou qu'on
juge extrémistes
ça montre que toutes les solutions n'ont
pas été apportées aux problèmes de ces
gens là évidemment et ça nous ramène à
trump aux états unis mais ça on va se
réserver beaucoup de cette analyse là
pour le deuxième tour on verra si ça se
confirme est effectivement dire que ne
pas regarder un problème ne ne fait pas
disparaître le problème il ya des gens
qui disent on a envie d'une manière plus
forte à tort ou à raison parce qu'ils
ont peur peut-être été écoutés michel c
je vous pose la même question est ce que
l a assez habilement
nos pains édulcorée mais elle a évité de
parler des éléments les plus pointues de
son programme pour ce pour finalement
parler des choses que les gens
connaissaient bien la tva qu'on voulait
exclure sur les biens essentiels baisser
les taxes sur l'essence et ses
raisons et le masque et son programme
pour l'essentiel sur l'europe sur
l'immigration ces choses là le problème
c'est que les autres candidats n'ont pas
me sens en relief les autres candidats
et puis appliquer la règle quand on
applique dans une gamelle électorale
quand on est dans l'opposition on ferait
on frappe sur celui qui est au pouvoir
donc on a pu s'attaquer macron qu'on a
regardé le programme de madame le pen
même du côté de la gauche et tout ça
alors c'est pour ça que le débat va être
complètement différent pour le deuxième
tour si tu atteins que ce soit madame le
pen contre monsieur macron ya une
tradition à patrice temps des soirées
électorales françaises on n'a pas le
droit quand on est en france de donner
des résultats avant 20 heures mais les
belges font toujours le même coup ils
font des sondages de sortie des jeux rue
dams alors alors je ne vous donne pas
les résultats parce que je ne crois pas
aux sondages de sortie des urnes à
l'aide a fermé ses séries si c'est rien
c'est serré vers nous et attendre oui
exactement et ce ne l'était pas il ya
trois semaines la défense disent non à
tout ce ne l'était pas il y a trois
semaines on se disait même bon ben on va
envoyer dix jours on va demander
beaucoup aux gens parce que macron c'est
une formalité on va faire deux grandes
émissions politiques et hop les choses
commencent à bouger et comme vous dites
je veux pas faire de parallèle et
l'intro avec les états unis mais y'a un
vote de protestation en france qui est
là on a vu les jets les jambes bien sûr
2017 2018 mais il ya un vote de
protestation qui cherche qui cherche qui
remplira père ont été perdus mais qui
cherche une voile
oui et puis et puis c'est effectivement
ce qu'on disait en début d'émission
c'est à dire que on a tellement dit aux
gens depuis 6 - 8 mois voire plus c'est
plié n'y allez pas finalement c'est plié
puisque ce sera macron le pen et puis à
la fin ce sera macron donc c'est vrai
que d'abord pendant très longtemps cette
campagne va intéresser personne et puis
c'est en fin de campagne que les gens se
sont finalement intéressés à ce qui se
passe et que macron a sûrement qu
emmanuel macron pardonnez-moi a sûrement
regardé ça d'un peu haut en disant il a
quand même dit au départ je serai
président jusqu'au bout et candidat
quand je pourrai et oui mais sauf qu'une
campagne c'est une campagne et d'autres
pendant ce temps là était déjà parti et
vous l'avez dit un certain nombre de
problèmes qui n'ont pas été réglés
pendant son pendant ce quinquennat et
pendant évidemment lé quinquennat
précédent qui ressorte là parce que
encore une fois cette élection
présidentielle c'est l'élection la plus
importante chez nous même les gens qui
ne votent pas aux municipales aux
régionales ou départementales aux
européennes au référendum normalement
ils vont quand même voter parce que un
président c'est censé régler mes
problèmes les problèmes de chacun
d'entre nous et quand il ne le fait pas
il peut le payer et c'est vrai qu'un
président chez vous a beaucoup de
pouvoir donc si vous vous à tous de
pouvoir mathieu par l'un d'eux de macron
son bilan alors vous parliez vous
évoquez les gilet jaune effectivement
son quinquennat a commencé par une
révolte sociale axée sur le pouvoir
d'achat les gilet jaune c'était sein
pendant plusieurs mois cette
contestation qui s'est soldée ouvriers
par quatre morts il ya eu si main
arrachée c'est ce qu'on attend d'eux
comptabilisé 30 personnes qui ont perdu
un oeil puis on a ensuite organisé
pendant deux mois un grand débat
national pour essayer d'aller chercher
le pouls des français et faire des
propositions pour sortir de la crise
cette crise qui s'est essoufflé aussi
avec avec l'arrivée de la pandémie autre
polémique il ya eu cette affaire en 2018
la sphère benalla
alexandre ménard était un chargé de
mission pour pour l'elysée qui a été
pris en flagrant délit de violence sur
sur des manifestants et on a reproché à
emmanuel macron ne pas avoir réagi assez
vite il a été condamné avec son benalla
il n'ya pas longtemps à trois ans de
prison autre polémique plus récente
celle ci raphaël bouvier au cléri il
faisait référence tout à l'heure la
polémique qu'on appelle un peu la ferme
mckinsey pourquoi mckinsey c'est un de
plusieurs cabinets de conseil privé
auquel l'état un fait appel et l'état à
une commission sénatoriale
a trouvé quel est l'état avait dépensé
un milliard d'euros seulement en 2021
pour faire des diagnostics sur la
société faire des propositions chose que
théoriquement les fonctionnaires du
gouvernement sont capables de faire donc
ça a été reprochée d'autant plus que
mckinsey il était découvert que par des
stratagèmes d'optimisation fiscale n'a
pas payer d'impôts en france ces
dernières années quelques chiffres pour
terminer quand même sur le bilan
économique des manuels macron en ce qui
concerne justement cette thématique du
pouvoir d'achat bien le bilan n'est pas
si mauvais puisque vous voyez que ça
augmentait de 5 4% là évidemment ce
n'est pas uniforme dans la société et ce
qu'on reproche d'ordinaire elle mène au
lac on se vérifie ici aussi c'est à dire
que les plus riches se sont également
plus enrichie en ce qui concerne le
chômage la note est très bonne pourquoi
parce qu'on est en france à 7 4% de
chômeurs ce qui est le taux le plus bas
depuis 2008 donc c'est effectivement le
gouvernement peut s'enorgueillir et
concernant la croissance le pib malgré
les années de pandémie avec le
ralentissement est bien il a quand même
crû de 4,6 pour cent donc certains des
indicateurs sont au vert pour emmanuel
macron mais effectivement il a tardé à
entrer en campagne ça va lui coûter
peut-être quelques points parce que au
début de la guerre en ukraine il était à
plus de 30% d'intentions de vote il n'a
perdu au moins six ou sept points depuis
depuis trois ou quatre semaines donc à
voir à quel point ce sera serré comme
michel le disait là dans quelques
minutes dans douze minutes exactement et
si elle devait parce que la personne qui
arrive de vinci
ainsi qu'aux logiquement ça serait un
choc mais je ça ne change pas tant les
choses imaginons qu'elle a un point de
pourcentage de plus que lui au premier
tour il y aurait un double choc mais on
repart à zéro quand même un parfait mais
c'est ce que je disais il faudra
regarder son score et sa place parce que
malgré tout si elle arrive en tête alors
là on rentre aussi dans une autre
dynamique
candidate de l'extrême droite qui arrive
en tête du scrutin présidentiel
ce serait évidemment du jamais vu et là
quand même même si emmanuel macron est à
quelques centièmes de points derrière à
un point derrière on pourrait se dire oh
bah si on fait des additions sauf que
vous l'avez dit les additions ça ne
marche plus c'est à dire que on aura
beau faire toutes les consignes de votes
possibles et inimaginables on additionne
pas le nombre par exemple de anne
hidalgo fabien roussel qui est le
candidat communiste
yannick jadot qui le candidat écologiste
pour dire pour ces gens là ils disent de
voter macron on va additionner leurs
voix ça ne marche pas comme ça il y a de
fait le score et la place du premier
tour donne à chacun des candidats et des
candidates le cas échéant une dynamique
qui est différente mais pour quelles
raisons d'après vous hélène les français
auraient envie pour ne sais pas si ça
sera le cas ou pas mais aurait envie
d'un moment le pen dans leur vie
politique quel serait selon vous les
facteurs les plus importants qui aurait
pu expliquer ce qui pourrait expliquer
une mondialisation qui a qui n'a pas
bénéficié à tout le monde qui a inquiété
un certain nombre de gens donc il ya une
une perte de repères identitaires que
l'on peut regretter mais qui existent en
france qui existe ailleurs évidemment
dans plein d'autres pays vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure des états unis c'est une
des raisons cette espèce de de crise
identitaire finalement est-ce que je
suis bien dans dans le pays dans lequel
mon grand père mon arrière grand père a
vécu est ce que les étrangers qui
aujourd'hui forment la communauté
nationale est ce que je me sens proche
d'eux est ce qu'ils ne sont pas
favorisés par rapport à moi et puis
quand même tout un problème donc ça
c'est le
l'interrogation identitaire culturelle
qui est quand même très forte en france
même si on a vu que par exemple aux
problèmes d'immigration arrive
aujourd'hui assez loin dans le temps en
terme d'enjeu pour pour le vote mais
n'empêche qu'il
il est là évidemment et puis il ya quand
même un aspect économique et social où
il ya vous l'avez dit plutôt de bons
résultats objectivement oui je sais la
question mais qui n'a pas bénéficié à
tout le monde et même si on sait
aujourd'hui que le pouvoir d'achat des
classes moyennes est allé plus tôt
croissant avec emmanuel macron l'image
de président des riches qu'il a eu à
peine installé à l'elysée en 2017 parce
qu'il a supprimé un impôt qui était un
impôt emblématique symbolique pour les
français qui étaient l'impôt sur la
fortune cette image de président des
riches ubiq colle à la peau et donc les
classes moyennes françaises qui continue
quand même de certes qui ont vu leur
pouvoir d'achat augmenter un petit peu
mais qui ont l'impression c'est toujours
de plus en plus durs que leurs enfants
vont avoir une vie plus compliquée que
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'ascenseur
social républicain qui étiez qui serait
en panne chez nous tout cela peut-être
tous un certain nombre d'électeurs à
dire et si on tentait autre chose voilà
il si on tentait autre chose et ceux qui
croyaient que c'était pas possible par
les anges américains ils ont tenté
monsieur tron qui avait des raisons
sociologiques t'es pas qu' il fallait
prendre au sérieux ces appels aussi de
plusieurs électeurs qui devait on a
envie de quelqu'un qui nous prend au
sérieux devant lui jusqu'où est allé de
ce nom de questions on peut aller voir
eli
à montréal dans ce rassemblement alors
élise sonné je rappelle à 8 minutes
maintenant des résultats qui parmi les
douze candidats
seront au deuxième tour ce que ça sera
bel et bien madame le pen et monsieur
macro à voir et vous il ya plus d'action
le les gens ont hâte de savoir
au oui à beaucoup plus de gens sur place
on préfère un tour de la salle je me
trouve à l'union française de montréal
dans les locaux de cette association qui
représente des expatriés français et je
me suis bien entouré aujourd'hui me suis
entouré de gens qui ont milité pour
différents partis de la gauche de la
droite de la seine au centre ou
également et je vais me tourner vers le
militant de la france est soumise
thibault frelich bonjour bonjour vous
vous avez senti que les français de
montréal mais il était beaucoup pour
jean luc mélenchon c'est ce que vous
prenez parti dans cette histoire cette
pauvre êtes vous militez pour la france
est soumise mais qu'est ce que vous en
avez ressenti les français le à montréal
mais j'ai senti une volonté de
changement qui est très forte évidemment
la communauté étaient très mobilisées
autour des enjeux qui nous touche touche
en fait la question écologique est
vraiment une question transversale qui
occupe beaucoup les esprits le rapport
du giec qui est sorti récemment montrent
qu'on ne peut plus continuer dans le
chemin dans lequel on et ça ça avait
beaucoup revenus la question écologique
la crise démocratique aussi beaucoup
nous en ont parlé il pense que la vème
république doit être changée pour
d'avoir des institutions plus
démocratiques évidemment la crise
sociale on
on entend beaucoup parler puisqu'il ya 9
millions de pauvres en france et c'est
un problème majeur qui n'a pas été
résolu tu vois ces dernières années mais
vous savez que les sondages je n'aime
pas nécessairement monsieur mélenchon
pour le second tour là on penche
davantage vers madame le pen et monsieur
macro nous verrons ce que les yeux ne
décidons on a déjà eu des sondages qui
se sont trompés à la dernière minute
mais à ce moment là on peux pas encore
en parler moi je leur tour qu'on a sur
le terrain c'est une forte mobilisation
à fort retour positif et donc on a
toutes les raisons d'être confiant
je suis aussi avec une femme qui a
milité pour emmanuel macron john
d'ailleurs vers le privé c'est beau de
voir des jeunes et piqué en pole c'est
comme ça alors oui dites moi comment
avez-vous c'est un petit les français
morgan par rapport à la république en
marge par rapport au parti de m bien sûr
les français ici à moelle ils sont très
intéressés par une multitude de sujets
l'égalité femmes hommes c'est une des
grandes causes du quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron puisque avec
l'allongement du congé paternité la pma
pour tout beaucoup de beaucoup de
mesures qui ont été mises en place sur
laquelle on a pu échanger avec les
français ici l'écologie avec la
convention citoyenne pour le climat qui
au delà d'être une innovation
démocratique a porté ses fruits en
matière d'enjeux climatique à apporter
des solutions
et puis tout un tout un tas de sujets
mais au final ce qui revient le plus
c'est que le bilan des manuels macron
c'était son programme en 2017 et les
français ça le reconnaissent et on a pu
échanger avec eux sur toutes les
avancées qui ont été faits par le
gouvernement
2010 est à 2022 vous sentez vous à
quelques minutes du dévoilement du
résultat pas forcément impatient de voir
les résultats mais je pense qu'on peut
aussi être très fier de la campagne
qu'on a su mener parce qu'il faut se
rappeler que derrière emmanuel macron
c'est tout un tas de partis qui étaient
mobilisés le mouvement démocrate la
république en marche horizon agir
territoire de progrès parti qui sont
derrière la république en marche finale
exactement derrière la majorité
présidentielle et qui ensemble forment
la majorité présidentielle et qui ont su
travailler ensemble sur le terrain
pendant toutes ces semaines de campagne
vous avez travaillé fort pour mesures
macro alors on va voir s'il va ressortir
comme les sondages les aigles de ce
premier tour exactement on espère qu'il
sera au deuxième tour et on continuera
de se mobiliser pendant les deux
prochaines semaines s'il y est bien sûr
on a reproché d'ailleurs à monsieur
macron de ne pas faire suffisamment
campagne peut-être ce sera différent
pour les deux prochaines semaines et si
on a le temps j'aimerais me tourner vers
quelqu'un qui a milité pour le parti
d'eric zemmour conca est un nouveau
parti de droite ont comme celui de m le
pen et comment au 5 et madame le pen
passera sans doute au second tout cas ce
qu'à vous comment vous vous sentez pas
cessé de vous déçu que monsieur zemmour
et d'essence dans les sondages quelques
quelques semaines avant avant l'élection
au premier tour on est toujours déçu
lorsqu'on perd des voix c'est normal
qu'on a vu une pente descendante
mais il ya un renouveau pour nous de
toute façon la recomposition va
recommencer à l'issue de ces élections
donc c'est ça il faut voir le positif et
je pense que nos idées ont été émises au
sein de la de la campagne donc c'était
un combat finalement de civilisation et
ce qui est ce qui est enthousiasmant
pour nous c'est qu'effectivement
l'avenir ça sera pour nous parce qu'on
était un jeune parti de toute façon
en un mot allez vous voter pour marine
le pen si elle passe au second tour
alors on verra parce que là on est à
quelques minutes du résultat donc on
sais pas peut-être qu'il y aura une
surprise on n'a pas encore les résultats
officiels mais c'est certain que
on verra on verra on verra on doit y
aller on vous en dévoilera les résultats
très bientôt et on vous reviendra avec
la réaction des gens là mais très bonnes
questions et lille c'était la question à
poser est effectivement est ce que eric
zemmour et ses partisans vont donc en
grand nombre les joindre les rangs de
madame le pen on peut passer que oui
hélène jouan nous soulignait tout à
l'heure ce serait totalement incohérent
si ce n'était pas le cas là on aura
merci et la zone euro les résultats et
on va d'ailleurs pendant quelques
secondes laissées l'antenne à france 2
pour nous donner savait que les soirées
électorales labeouf quand même des
parenthèses aimerait du coup à 30
secondes 40 ils commencent leur soirée
électorale qu'ils ont les résultats
comme ça d'un cool parce qu'ils ont
c'est pas des sondages en sorties de
bureaux de vote il y a des bureaux de
vote qui sont des bureaux tests alors
ici comme un immense ondam je vous
voulez avec un échantillon
très très grand et donc avec des
résultats très précis ce que vous allez
voir comme chiffre apparaît dans deux
trois heures ça sera à peu près les
mêmes chiffres il ya des petits
ajustements pourtant les rédactions
n'ont accès qu'à ses bureaux de vote
témoins alors c'est une façon de faire
leur leurs soirées électorales il n'y a
pas de suspense et de l'analyse parce
qu'ils ont déjà les résultats oui les
résultats qui vont effectivement pris
sur des bureaux tests sur les bureaux de
vote les principaux ferment à 20h mais
ceux qui ferment à 19 heures me sont
sélectionnés effectivement pour avoir
cette estimation et on l'a vu ça s'est
vérifié effectivement dans les autres
présidentielle ce qui sort à 20h14 notre
heure est sensiblement le résultat final
un mot quand même peu importe les
résultats qui vont arriver là dans
quelques secondes
l'extrême droite devrait devenir pour la
première fois la plus grande famille
politique en france si on additionne les
scores de marine le pen et d'eric
zemmour peu importe qui se qualifie et
ça c'est quelque chose qui t'a à noter
dans la recomposition du paysage
politique français c'est inédit la seule
fois où l'extrême droite a été au
pouvoir on parle pas de pouvoir
évidemment ici mais en france étaient
sous pétain pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et là on voit effectivement
depuis 2000 la campagne que marine le
pen s'en rapproche elle n'a jamais été
aussi proche du pouvoir et elle est
beaucoup mieux préparé qu'elle ne
l'était en 2017 si jamais elle accède au
2e tour ça sera pas du tout
l'entre-deux-tours de 2017 elle va être
beaucoup plus prête et notamment pour le
débat c'est son moment si elle a une
chance d'arriver au pouvoir c'est
maintenant et est d'ailleurs il ya un
grand risque pour emmanuel macron on l'a
dit tout à l'heure il pourra quand même
la mettre l'accent sur ce qui n'a pas
été ce sur quoi on n'a pas appuyé jusque
jusqu'à présent c'est-à-dire quand même
ces liens très étroits avec
vladimir poutine avec les démocraties et
libérale européenne donc ça ce sera
quelque chose qu'elle va devoir gérer en
revanche on avait on a parlé aussi d'un
mot du débat de l'entre-deux tours elle
avait été calamiteuse si vous permettez
l'explorant les côtes les résultats
parlent à lens il est 20 heures voici le
résultat de ce premier tour en tête ce
soir emmanuel macron avec 28,1 % devant
marine le pen avec
23,3 pour cent la même affiche qu'en
2010 apparaît au terme de ce premier
tour vous voyez les les deux sujets avec
l'explosion de joie dans les deux qg
voici la suite des résultats avec avec
anne-sophie oui à la troisième place
jean luc mélenchon avec un gros score
20,1 pour cent plus plus important
encore qu'en 2010 est derrière eric
zemmour mais loin derrière à 7,2 pour
cent suivent valérie pécresse 5% enfin
l'écologiste et yannick jadot 4,4 pour
cent
jean lassalle à 3,3 pour cent il devance
fabien roussel le communiste 2,7 pour
cent nicolas dupont aignan à 2,3 pour
cent puis notez à 2,1 pour cent la
socialiste anne hidalgo enfin ce sont
les deux candidats d'extrême gauche qui
ferme la marche nathalie arthaud à 0 8%
et fait du poutou à 0 7% on va prendre
tout de suite la direction des qg du
soir des deux candidats arrivés en tête
il se retourne ça sera un deuxième tour
emmanuel macron et marine le pen
monsieur macron qui a 28 pour ça on doit
pouvoir y aller dès que l'on peut vous
voyez des images en direct du camp de
monsieur macron on doit mieux respirer
quoique là tout recommence à zéro pour
le deuxième tour mon doigt mieux
respirer avec le score de 28 % et madame
le pen 23%
loin monsieur blanc mélenchon ou 20% lui
il dira je vous le prédis déjà si ça va
durer deux trois semaines de plus il
aurait peut-être été au second tour à
voir mais bref et il y à des constats
sidérant pour ceux qui suivent la
politique française depuis longtemps
anne hidalgo arrive presque bondé bonne
dernière 2% derrière le commu nes
derrière le trotskiste derrière le jeu
jadot le
le chef des verts
derrière jean lassalle qui est un peu
passé moi l'expression mais un clown
folklorique
la ruralité alors c'est intéressant tour
de table rapide avant d'aller sur le
terrain hélène une bonne nouvelle
raphaël est là et oui allons bien sûr à
faire
raphaël alors
soulagement malgré tes c'est 1 28%
j'imagine qu'on a aimé voir apparaître
oui et on la sent si dans les
applaudissements les cris des militants
d' emmanuel macron maintenant soit sont
réunis dans le sud de paris parce qu'ils
vont savoir patrice qu'en france on ne
peut pas dévoiler les premières
estimations avant 20 heures pile mais
chez les voisins belges on n'est pas
touché par cette loi là donc on voyait
apparaître au cours des dernières heures
des premières estimations venant de
médias belge a indiqué que marine le pen
et emmanuel macron étaient au coude à
coude environ 24% charrier j'en ai on
sentait la nervosité
dans des manuels métrange par le min
alors qu'ils aient effectivement là on
n'est pas dans la même dynamique qui dit
américain alors finalement monsieur
maquereau a quand même quelques points
de pourcentage devant marine le pen ce
sera donc une reprise de 2007 mais les
militants des manuels mal vendu son
entourage donc savent très bien que le
contexte n'est pas le même et qu'on ne
pourra pas faire abstraction de la
campagne qu'a réussi à faire marine le
pen de cette image qui a été dé
diaboliser comme disent certains membres
de l'entourage de monsieur magri donc on
va entendre de plus en pour premières
utilisées qu'à l'endroit marine le pen
sur des dossiers comme la russie sur des
dossiers l'économie et on va peut-être
aussi boire davantage me suis ma croûte
de cul sur le terrain parce qu'on a nos
abris tout au long de cette sélection
emmanuel macron et bruce lee tantrique
elle me sert d'aliment dans l'arène
électorale jeudi dix ans pour
l'attribution de président chef d'état
était sûrement en ce moment et
finalement réalise que la campagne
baisse à son poste à son indépendance et
notamment on réalise que ces enjeux sur
lesquels a misé marie le pen par exemple
l'enjeu du pouvoir d'achat il est très
très important du l'on verra mais dans
quel message adressez menu maxi l
électorat tenté de tendre une main vers
la droite d'une classique l'idée est
qu'ils n'ont pas connue et très bon
score ce soir vers la gauche on voit que
monsieur mélenchon la gauche radicale
obtenu mais pour cent du vote quand même
mais on sait que son électorat est
plutôt critique même si l'inde emmanuel
macron pouvoir alors ce sera à suivre
mais déterrement emmanuel du trou
devrait être présent il ya des leçons
qui devrait avoir été de cv de cette
première partie de campagne où il malgré
ce score qui a fait en sorte que oui on
a quand même senti un soupir de
soulagement ici à la porte de gentilly
cela je comprends pas ce que 24 24 a été
une autre histoire la faille aller des
jeux mathématiques
bien sûr les gens vont additionner les
7,2 pour cent des reggae moore à madame
le pen mélenchon c'est l'aîné le vin
pour ça comme vous dites il va aller en
partie du côté de macramé en partie du
côté de le pen ce que c'est le tiers la
demie bien malin celui qui pourrait
prédire mais ce qui nous place dans une
grande incertitude quant aux résultats
finaux du deuxième tour comme vous dites
ce n'est pas bouclé il devra se relever
les manches et faire campagne à un débat
souligne on leur a fait l important
prévu le 20 entre les deux candidats et
le débat ça avait été un moment très
important dans la campagne de 2010 est
clairement le camp d'emmanuel macro va
miser sur cet événement pour marquer des
points auprès de l'état très bien est ce
que vous croyez qu'ils la voyant les
résultats oui petit soulagement mais
qu'il a quand même des regrets où il se
dit dans le fond je n'aurais pas pu
compte tenu de la dynamique des extrêmes
un peu de mélenchon de le pen zemmour je
n'aurais pas pu faire mieux et ceux qui
perdent totalement la face ce sont la
droite traditionnelle et les socialistes
qui disparaissent du radar
oui tout à fait carte politique qui
était déjà en transformation pas crise
en france depuis l'élection 2009 et on
envoie la continuité voir le résultat ce
soir avec ses performances de la droite
républicaine traditionnels les
républicains et puis du parti socialiste
vous le mentionnez à peine 2 % des voix
pour anne hidalgo donc à une
reconstruction tête échiquier politique
là monsieur macron s'est présenté comme
étant au centre a dirigé trop à droite
selon bien des militants de gauche on
l'a entendu lors de son rassemblement
faire des promesses au niveau social
pour tenter de plaire aux électeurs de
gauche en même temps l'une de ses
grandes promesses elle ne plaît pas la
gauche et de repousser l'âge de la
retraite à 65 ans alors quand on se
présente au centre aussi il ya un défi
stratégique quand il faut rallier des
voix lors du deuxième tour et ça ce sera
vraiment l'enjeu majeur lors des
prochaines semaines au cours des deux
des deux prochaines semaines
maintenant est ce qu'il ya des regrets
c'est clair que comme
militant tout à l'heure mais le fait de
ne pas avoir été davantage sur le
terrain ça peut avoir joué en même temps
l'enjeu en europe l'enjeu de la guerre
il est très important la france avait un
rôle à jouer dans cette dans ce confrère
et monsieur maquereau a joué un rôle
mais maintenant il faut trouver la
balance et à être sur le terrain au
cours des deux prochaines semaines petit
détail est ce que vous connaissez
l'heure du discours de monsieur macron
parce que mesdames et messieurs il y
aura bien sûr les discours on va suivre
donc à quelle heure doit-il parler
alors emmanuel macron à regarder les
résultats à l'elysée avec son entourage
a déjà des membres de son entourage qui
sont ici dans le sud de paris il va
arriver donc au cours des prochaines
heures discours prévu 21h heure locale
donc 15 heures ne m'ont rien donc moins
d'une heure c'est noté 15 heures
monsieur macron merci merci raphaël je
sais pas si la fenêtre ça fait de nous
permettre vous garder mais tant mieux si
vous michel ses premières premier
commentaire face à ces chefs la ja il y
en a pour tout le monde là
il ya un an pour tout le monde ya un
gros ouf schéma qu'on sait sur quatre un
peu plus que quatre points d'avancé par
la quasi égalité que ça fait aux
différences il va y avoir des normes
règlements de comptes à gauche seule
asie ça commence à se dire et se disait
dans les derniers jours de la campagne
si roussel s'était retiré pour pour
mélenchon évidemment peu pour faire le
report de votre mathématiques mais
mélenchon serait au deuxième tour et
c'est vraiment ce que mélenchon va dire
c'est à ses partisans et où ils vont
aller parce qu'ils suivront peut-être
pas la consigne qui va être assez
important dans ce deuxième couronne
c'est un peu lui l' arbitre du deuxième
tour et 20 pour ça c'est quand même
beaucoup mieux que tout le monde
attendait de son côté même si il est en
croissance dans les sondages d'un
dernières semaines on l'a vue là les
sondages et ils ont quand même un peu
menti sur la façon prévue vote de
monsieur de web il fait mieux que prévu
et et monsieur macro femme est prévu
aussi alors il faudra voir ce que ça
donne mais je vous dis qu'à gauche ça
brasse beaucoup et qu'il va y avoir
beaucoup de gens qui vont dire si on là
il faut commencer à parler un peu plus
de gauche - fracturé bas si on n'ira
jamais nulle part oui puis sinon va
disparaître complètement 2% les
socialistes ccpo wheels et roule je peux
sont déjà arrivés à 0 mais le
chroniqueur politique en france que
c'est une blague peut-être qu'on va le
voir avec les deux essais 0 eva et les
républicains à 5% avec le tutu ramasser
les pots cassés bien y avoir des
règlements de compte et la première
première premier commentaire qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire divine surprise pour
emmanuel macron il termine à 28 11 %
c'est quasiment le score qui l'avait en
début de campagne quand tout le monde
disait non mais ça c'est le début il va
forcément des cendres et de fait on l'a
vu beaucoup d'essence dans ces dernières
semaines
28,11 il fait 5 points de plus que
marine le pen c'est à dire qu'il a accru
l'écart avec marine le pen par rapport à
2010 est alors ça veut pas dire
évidemment que l'élection est joué
ça veut dire qu'il ya qu on efface tout
ce qu'on me disait on recommence une
nouvelle dynamique qui va falloir aller
chercher des voix à gauche et il n'y a
pas beaucoup de réservoir de voix
notamment dans là dans la gauche
républicaine on l'a dit un parti
socialiste qui n'existe quasiment plus
une droite républicaine qui perd 15
points par rapport à 2010 est donc là
c'est l'effondrement général donc où
emmanuel macron va-t-il pouvoir aller
chercher
ces voix pour être en tête au deuxième
tour ça reste compliqué mais ce soir
c'est quand même une divine surprise
effondrement on l'a dit des parties
schéma l'enchanterait moi de vous couper
gmail un champ il pas l'un chercher un
peu mc ren bien sûr qu'il peut aller en
chercher un peu parce que il y a encore
des gens chez mélenchon qui se disent
tous sauf l'extrême droite tout sauf
marine le pen
donc oui il y a des gens qui vont avoir
le réflexe du front républicain mais pas
100 % de l'électorat mélenchon ce qu'on
a vu avant le premier tour un tiers
allez sur macron un tiers abstentions un
tir le pen est ce que là ça va être
modifié ça reste à voir très bien
mathieu prost nouvelle dynamique qui
commence à partir de maintenant anne
hidalgo on vient de parler des malheurs
des socialistes qui endosse emmanuel
macron les gens vont dire bon mais très
bien mais elle à mane les trois amis à
2% effectivement elle a plus aucun poids
dans ce jeu là peu importe la consigne
de vote ça ne fera pas de différence je
suis quand même amusé à additionner les
scores des partis de gauche on arrive à
32 8 % s'il y avait eu hypothétiquement
une candidature unitaire évidemment on
peut pas faire d'arithmétique on l'a dit
mais on aurait été peut-être dans ces
eaux là mais il ya pas eu de primaire à
gauche n'y a pas eu de candidature
unitaire l'extrême droite on additionne
zemmour le pen et nicolas dupont aignan
dont on a peu parlé mais qui est un
candidat qui est très très très à droite
sur l'échiquier aussi on arrive à 32 5%
donc immense famille politique en ce
moment qu'un tiers un tiers un tiers
avec mc ren exactement pour jean luc
mélenchon oui ça va être compliqué et il
y est ça va être ça va être à mots
couverts la consigne de vote parce que
il a très bien fait savoir qu'il ne
voulait pas se présenter comme ce qu'il
appelle le roi des castors pourquoi le
roi des castors c'est celui qui
construit des barrages faire barrage au
front national il ne veut pas de ce rôle
là et il condamne d'ailleurs emmanuel
macron qui va appeler au vote et au
front républicain et qui ont essayé
d'aller siphonner les voix chez jean luc
mélenchon pour essayer de gonfler son
score alors évidemment c'est extrêmement
extrêmement impressionnant en fait ces
résultats est la faiblesse des résultats
des très grandes familles politiques 2%
pour une dalle co 5 % pour valérie
pécresse c'est un effondrement c'est
vraiment une dislocation total est ce
que c'est la fin de ces grands partis
peut-être parce que l'assise
probablement des manuels macron sur la
vie politique et de son parti l'a puni
qu'en marche va encore s'accroître il ya
les législatives les élections des
députés qui viennent après la
présidentielle et ça va se confirmer
dans le paysage très bien et béraud vous
êtes au rassemblement de marine le pen
bon on est content c'est leur match dont
on avait parlé néanmoins on arrête un
peu plus content si on avait fait 1
34.2 plus de pourcentage
l'écart est moins serrés que ce que
laissaient présager les sondages donc
lui ici à une clameur l'accord se sont
affichées les deux visages des listes
pour le second tour à l'écran géant que
vous voyez derrière moi vous savez il ya
des liens fonda rebours avant les
quelques minutes avant de se dévoiler on
entendu les partisans ici libre et
anthony est la marseillaise d'irma
nouristan ils ont recommencé aussi une
foi des résultats affichés donc
soulagement oui pour ce qui était un peu
fébrile
déception chez ceux qui étaient très
confiants dans cette salle est beaucoup
plus serré voire peut-être marine le pen
dit termine première au premier tour
mais bon voilà presque sait que pour
scinder car si je calcule rapidement et
si je regarde des lichettes donc
maintenant quelle est la suite d'une
question de report des voix on voit que
les zemmouris a fait son sport est
beaucoup plus faible selon les
estimations la que prévu il est derrière
jean-luc mélenchon des de l'union
populaire là les uniques et se présente
l'avenir
quel sera le report des voix des prix
des sondages prédisaient qu en cas de
deuxième tour avec marine le pen au
moins 80% des parties sans d'eric
zemmour la rejoindrait mais ce sera
assez on sait que marine le pen a fait
appel non seulement la mobilisation lors
de son dernier grand rassemblement mais
la nation un appel aussi à tous les
français qui sont désabusés parce qu'ils
ont vu depuis cinq ans qui veut le
changement dit une femme à l'elysée ce
serait un beau changement pourquoi pas
et l'asie si vous voulez changer de
politique qu'il faut changer les
politiques dont qu'elle appelait tous
les patriotes ce soit dans ses membres
de droit tout ce qu'elle qualifie de
gauche que ceux qui aiment la france
est-ce que cet appel sera entendu pour
l'instant je sais que l'on derrière moi
des militants
tout arrêt de bus est
vrai que j'aurais voulu le regarder un
adversaire de marine le pen ou encore
des propos qui ne leur plaisent pas mais
on devrait savoir que voudra se
rejoindre marine le pen répondre à son
appel nous on a déjà croisé des
militants des électeurs français
françaises
jusqu'à tout récemment votés pour la
droite votait braqueront emmanuel macron
dit on lit déçu par ce canard il peut
changer d'autres disent aussi ben par le
marine le pen cartel le ticket veut
aider les jeunes qui a indiqué peut
aider toutes les classes moyennes
populaire
à quand elle dit que l'argent pour
dépenser de l'argent pour les français
de positions sont prises avec l'intérêt
d'y penser en terme
qui va se joindre à elle a second tour
quel jour là quelques jours qui commande
une nouvelle campagne et l'internement
ce débat de l'entre-deux tours pour me
surveiller avec prudence oui c'est
exactement ça la question qu'est ce que
doit se poser elle doit additionner doit
10 youn et est dépassé macron qui lui
aussi va dit sio nez
des vagues et c'est là où elle doit voir
même si on le verra pas dans son
discours mais quand même une légère
déception on aurait aimé mieux que
comporte le deuxième tour armes égales
ce qui n'est pas le cas si elle
additionne zemmour si elle additionne
nicolas dupont
aignan donc on est à 33 c'est lui en lui
prend donc ce qui devient incontournable
mélenchon ça nous prendre partie du
gâteau de mélenchon celui à lui seul y
en a vingt alors où iront ces gens là
c'est là le gros point d'interrogation
et des raisons
j'ai mes raisons patrice on va
surveiller avec attention chaque mois
elle est entrée en ce moment où le temps
de retravailler son discours elle a
tenté agréablement comme nous tous de
voir quelles seraient les cas et donc
elle est ici madame quelque part dans le
pavillon on attend son discours aux
environs de 20h30 donc chaque mot là va
être analysé pour connaître donc elle a
parlé avant elle va essayer d'aller
chercher comme le veut la truelle à
20h30 c'était mais voilà voilà c'est ce
que c'est ce qu'on nous dit mais bon ça
reste encore à confirmer donc peut-être
quelques minutes à attendre encore bon
ben alors donc nous on a notre feuille
de route ça veut dire que dans quelques
milieux dans 15 minutes à peu près
madame
le pen va parler suivi de monsieur
macron et je sais pas si on aura
mélenchon une indication e de l'heure à
laquelle il est ce que nous avons encore
merci annick merci on va
on va se reparler merci beaucoup pendant
que vous allez y et valérie pécresse qui
avait gagné là la primaire de droite 54
ans madame pécresse qu'à cinq pour ça
c'est quand même une joie on va
l'écouter un peu si vous le permettez ce
résultat est évidemment une déception
personnelle et collective
j'assume en responsabilité toute ma part
dans cette défaite
à toutes celles et tous ceux qui m'ont
fait l'honneur de leur vote dans
l'hexagone outre-mer et à l'étranger je
veux leur dire ma reconnaissance et que
leur soutien est à jamais gravée dans
mon coeur je veux également remercier
l'équipe exceptionnelle de fidélité
d'engagement qui s'est démultiplié
partout sur le territoire pour porter
haut nos convictions et nos couleurs je
reste persuadé que notre projet
courageux et réformateurs et le bon pour
la france et pour nos compatriotes
après un quinquennat de crise
d'immobilisme et de louvoiement il faut
remettre de l'ordre dans le pays et il y
attend à reconstruire voilà pourquoi la
droite et le centre
solidement enracinée dans les
territoires ne doivent rien lâcher
ne pas se diviser ne pas renoncer à leur
valeur est mené avec détermination le
combat des législatives qui s'annoncent
le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle opposera donc à nouveau
emmanuel macron et marine le pen ce soir
je suis profondément inquiète pour
l'avenir de notre pays alors que
l'extrême droite n'a jamais été aussi
près de l'emporter
en épargnant au premier tour les
extrêmes et en esquivant le débat
démocratique emmanuel macron a joué avec
le feu et fait prendre un énorme risque
à la france nous pourrions tous en payer
le prix
vous le savez j'ai construit mon
engagement politique contre les extrêmes
de droite comme de ch je les ai toujours
combattue avec force et constance car je
crois comme jacques chirac
que tout dans l'âme de la france dit non
à l'extrémisme
le projet de marine le pen conduirait le
pays à la discorde à l'impuissance et à
la faillite sa proximité historique avec
vladimir poutine la discrédite pour
défendre les intérêts de notre pays dans
l'étang tragique que nous vivons son
élection on dirait à l'effacement de la
france sur les scènes européennes et
internationales
ainsi et malgré les profondes
divergences que j'ai martelé tout au
long de la campagne
je voterai en conscience emmanuel macron
pour empêcher l'arrivée au pouvoir de
marine le pen et le chaos qui en
résulterait je les dis alors voilà
valérie pécresse qui peut-être dans son
meilleur discours de la campagne jardin
termes des analystes où elle avait un
ton beaucoup plus posé plus réel enfin
bref ça c'est autre chose elle est
arrivée avec 5 % je vous le rappelle qui
dit que la france ne peut pas se
permettre
cinq années le pen que ce serait un
désastre que la seule proximité avec
vladimir poutine
disqualifie madame le pen pour devenir
président de la république française
c'était est-ce que c'était clair dans
votre esprit qu'elle irait jusque là
elle avait n'est pas une consigne de
vote sauf que l'aï dit quand même très
très clairement l'air chose en effet et
vous avez sans doute raison c'est sans
doute l'un des deux ses meilleurs
discours de campagne alors on est
souvent meilleur dans la défaite nicolas
sarkozy avec un excellentissime discours
de campagne lorsqu'il avait perdu la
présidentielle là c'est un discours en
responsabilité de valérie pécresse qui
prend acte évidemment de sa défaite elle
ne peut pas faire autrement qui dit ne
vous divisez pas ça c'est pas sûr que ça
marche parce que je pense que la
recomposition de la droite va commencer
très rapidement et ce n'est même pas sûr
que la famille de la droite arrive à se
tenir serrée jusqu'aux législatives qui
vont avoir lieu au mois de juin et puis
elle donne
manuel macro qui sans doute ce qui va
être un des arguments de cette campagne
de second tour la proximité de marine le
pen avec vladimir poutine
de laurentiis donne exactement elle
donne le narratif et elle soutient ce
narratif michel c je le dis j'ai écouté
quelques discours de mme pécresse
pendant la campagne où elle essayait
d'être quelqu'un d'autre elle était
elle-même aujourd'hui dans la défaite
well du bon ben ça sert à rien d'essayer
donc plus plus enracinées et ce qu'elle
dit de madame le pen ça donne des
arguments à monsieur macro
c'était ça va être son coeur ce discours
leur souvent dans la défaite on parle
plus avec son père que les discours les
deux meetings qu'elle a fait était au
zénith au début de la campagne de celui
de la semaine dernière si me souviens
bien elle parlait comme un robot c'était
vraiment de pénible à voir même alors là
elle donne des arguments et quand on
peut faire tous les scénarios de repli
qu'on veut des candidats qui seront pas
là au deuxième tour mais il va manquer
madame le pen ça va être compliqué pour
elles d'aller chercher 52% tu vois du
vote là dedans
mais ce que je sais ce que moi je note
dada dans les résultats du premier tour
si vous permettez pas triste bien sûr
prenez tous les partis qui rejette le
système c'est à dire le pen zemmour
mélenchon et les divers gauche là les
notes ce qui était tout ça il ya
cinquante deux 53% des français qui au
premier tour ont voté contre le système
c'est ça démontre que d'abord c'est un
pays qui est difficile à gouverner puis
deuxièmement que ya un mécontentement
profond dans ce pays là et ce qui va
être très intéressant de surveiller
quand on fera l'analyse du deuxième tour
c'est le nombre de gens et le taux de
participation le nombre de gens qui vont
rester chez eux parce que c'est bien
beau de dire vous êtes un partisan de
valérie pécresse qui vous aideront à la
ssii de quelles elles vont voter pour
pécresse va y aller moi aussi pas sûr
qu'ils vont faire ça pas sûr que les
gens surtout chez mélenchon vont dire
qu'ils ont voté pour lui 20% sait plus
que quiconque on pensait qu'ils vont
dire oh ouais mais ma croyez pas si mal
que ça après ou
alors si un ancien espoir qu'on aime le
panier dans l'abstention dans deux
semaines mais à première vue entre la
mathématique dit qu'il voyait
remarquable oui son sa route pour
arriver à la présidence michel est
beaucoup plus difficile il ya une
statistique m'en faudrait carré beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses pour que ça
se produise mais mathématiquement ce
n'est pas impossible non plus donc il
faut voir le jeu mais vous dites
politiquement
mathieu procès ce que vous disiez tout
cela quand vos calculs y est le score de
chacun son chemin il y en a il est plus
difficile et il faudrait vraiment
qu'elle aille chercher ces
abstentionnistes on a les résultats de
la participation c'est
26,2 pour cent cette année c'est quatre
points de plus l'abstention qu'en 2017
et il faut qu'elle aille chercher c'est
cet électorat-là qui naquit le va pas
voter parce que sont des catégories
généralement plutôt populaire et c'est
donc pour gonfler son score il faut
qu'elle aille dans ce sens la marine le
pen et oui elle peut elle peut être la
proie d'attaqués facile effectivement
valérie pécresse a donné vous le dites
les armes à emmanuel macron sur sa
proximité avec guti évidemment emmanuel
macron on va le dire mais vous continuez
de parler avec le président titi au
d'abstention exactement le taux
d'abstention et keita à 26 2% mais damas
continue de parler à un mur poutine en
tout cas il a continué à le faire très
longtemps jusqu'au début de cette
campagne n'est ce pas là mais chose
effectivement que d'aller serrer sa main
et d'avoir fait des tracts avec la photo
comme marine le pen ne l'a fait et
d'être financée par des dons lancé je
reviendrai en temps ça tout au long des
actes eux mans deux prochaines semaines
alors que l a été plutôt à l'abri de ces
attaques là pendant les trois dernières
semaines est ce qu'on se dit c'est que
eric zemmour a servi de paratonnerre
c'est à dire qu'il a pris toute la
foudre de sa proximité nuit avec
vladimir poutine voulait créer un
vladimir poutine à la française il le
disait et c'est lui qui a pris tout
l'opprobre de de cette proximité là
alors que marine le pen on a été épargné
il y à fort à parier que ce sera l'un
des arguments principaux l'un des
boutons sur lesquels emmanuel macron va
appuyer dans les prochains jours si
zemmour était à onze d'où ce serait une
autre histoire il est à 7,2 marion
maréchal lannes y est de de madame
marine le pen qui dit que monsieur
zemmour dans quelques milieux devra
appeler à voter le pen comme vous disiez
l'aisne c'est presque ne veut pas faire
autrement les spams il arrive avec 7 il
arrive pas avec 12 c'est quand même
encore une fois ça montre le chemin est
difficile de madame depuis le réservoir
de voix qu'elle l'attendait sur lequel
elle croyait pouvoir compter il ya
encore quelques jours n'est pas tout à
fait celui attendu moi j'ai du coup une
grande interrogation sait où sont passés
les électeurs de droite de la droite
républicaine
et bien visiblement certains bien sûr
sont allés un peu gonflé le score de
eric zemmour qui n'était pas là il ya
cinq ans ils sont partis un peu ch
emmanuel macron qui a augmenté son score
par rapport à il ya cinq ans mais on
sent qu'il ya quand même une espèce de
déperdition de 2
et presque on ne sait plus où ils sont
ces gens là
alors ça reste un réservoir de voix
notamment pour emmanuel macron
évidemment pour le second tour et
jadot qui pardonnez-moi enjoy années que
jadot le vert qui appellent à voter
macron il ya 4 % jade ou saas et l'autre
histoire dont on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
pourquoi le vote vers
le rendez vous avec les verts n'a jamais
vraiment eu lieu il n'y a pas eu de
connexion il semble un peu perdu dans
cette campagne est le sujet de la crise
les crises des changements climatiques
n'a pas émergé comme sujet du tout la
non ce qui est fou parce que pendant
pendant tout le quinquennat on a dit
mais c'est un des sujets majeurs et puis
parce qu'on voit bien que dans tous les
pays c'est effectivement ce qui monte
d'ailleurs la jeunesse notamment porte
cet espoir là et puis yannick jadot qui
a vécu une campagne compliquée à
l'intérieur même de son petit parti n'a
pas réussi à imposer une vision claire
de ce qu'il alors il a de ce qu'il
voulait pour pour changer de monde il a
beaucoup tapé sur emmanuel macron et sur
le bilan
climatique d'emmanuel macro mais ça n'a
effectivement pas suffi mais comme il
n'a pas suffi à nadi à anne hidalgo
elle non plus on voit que toute la
gauche est effectivement dans un état
assez qui prennent le train mélenchon
qu'il répare qui ont de grosses
différences go de vraiment de 2 bien sûr
qu'aujourd'hui jean luc mélenchon
s'affiche comme celui qui pourrait de
leader de la prochaine gauche même s'il
a quand même 70 ans c'est à dire que ce
n'est plus le c'était le plus âgé des
candidats mais aujourd'hui s'affiche
comme mais il ya de grandes lignes de
fracture entre lui et le parti
socialiste lui et les verts que ce soit
sur le nucléaire que ce soit sur
vladimir poutine aussi par exemple oui
mais s'il part peut-être quelques pour
faire la synthèse la gauche enfin on
verra ce soir ça sera dans la prochaine
michel sur jadot sur ces appels qui vont
venir aucune surprise la met mais comme
vous aimez aux alizés on sait déjà que
madame hidalgo et monsieur roussel aussi
10 de vote et mâcon alors les trois
partis traditionnels zoom permet tait de
la gauche avec l'hiver parce que ça ils
ont été ensemble leurs hôtes en dise de
voter macron déjà ça c'est c'est quelque
chose madame pécresse le dit aussi si ce
report la se fait dans des conditions
correctes
monsieur macouin des l'unsas et il
faudra voir évidemment la lahb station
parce que le parti si je reste à la
maison est toujours présent dans une
élection c'est toujours possible ça mais
on voit que ça s'enligne la crête qu'on
avait schéma conques le front
républicain puisse pas recréer ça semble
être en voie de se récréer moi j'ai hâte
de voir quelqu'un qui s'appelle eric
ciotti qui est probablement chez madame
pécresse chez les régler chez les
républicains la personne la plus à
droite c'est lui qui est arrivé
d'ailleurs du dixième dans la primaire
car s il est inutile d'ailleurs
oui beaucoup le géant devant lui qu'est
ce qu'il va dire parce que ça peut être
intéressant il dira pas devoir de voter
le pen je pense que ce serait
extraordinairement surprenant mais juste
mettre des réserves sur macro ce serait
déjà quelque chose à voir donc il faudra
voir ce qui va se passer puis évidemment
on attend mais dans journaux où on
attend mélenchon
dès qu'il parle monsieur mélenchon le on
essaiera de donner des grande partie
sinon on aura l'essentiel de ce qu'il
dit donc mathieu commence l'ordre
campagne l'autre campagne cette campagne
d'entre deux tours il y à un moment
évidemment qui est le moment phare c'est
le débat souvenez-vous 2017 petit
extrait
vous êtes en train de lire une fiche qui
ne correspond pas au dossier que vous
avez cités c'est triste pour vous parce
que ça montre votre impréparation à nos
concitoyens le dossier vendus contre les
intérêts de l'argent n'était pas
ministre pour sfr quant à general
electric alstom monsieur montebourg
s'est battu je me suis battu à ses côtés
pour que ce ne soit pas vendu on peut
rentrer si vous voulez dans l'intimité
du dossier vous n'allez pas tenir
longtemps parce que comme vous les
confondez les uns avec les autres il y
en a un qui fait des téléphones et
l'autre ça n'a rien à voir il fut à la
fois des turbines et du matériel
industriel c'est pas la même chose
il l'avait il faut le dire mathieu il
avait gagné haut la main ce débat là
elle est dans son camp dit elle était
fatiguée ça marchait pas elle avait six
de faire de l'ironie en parlant d' en
voulant rire un peu des arguments de
monsieur mac rompu qpr on la sentait
perdu un peu là où était autre chose
elle va arriver probablement mieux
préparés effectivement elle était
effectivement fatigué épuisé puis perdu
dans un programme qui était trop touffu
en 2010 cette nouvelle campagne
effectivement qui commence on a on a
deux semaines pour faire campagne on a
parlé un petit peu d'abord effectivement
les consignes de vote on les voit elles
sont en train de s'accumuler parfois à
demi mots comme valérie pécresse à deux
de front républicain
réellement à michel parler d'un d'eric
ciotti qui étaient effectivement à
l'adversaire de valérie pécresse lors de
la première les républicains ils
partagent un même slogan avec eric
zemmour l'a probablement qu'il
n'appellera pas à voter pour
marine le pen mais il devrait
effectivement oui critiquer ma nana
compte donc reports de voix a calculé
effectivement on fait quand même un peu
d'arithmétique même si c'est parfois
hasardeuse mais ça peut aider à voir
quelles sont les forces en présence on
se concentre là dessus on va écouter
marine le pen et on reviendra avec vos
mathématiques qui sont sa vente est
importante on écoute madame le pen
[Applaudissements]
mes chers compatriotes
français de métropole français
d'outre-mer et fonçait du monde
le peuple français s'est exprimé et me
fait l'honneur d'être qualifiés au
second tour face au président sortant
qu'il me soit permis d'exprimer aux
millions d'électeurs qui m'ont témoigné
leur confiance m'a plus sincère
gratitude
j'en mesure avec humilité toute la
responsabilité
j'y vois l'espoir l'espoir que se lèvent
les forces de redressement du pays
lors de ce premier tour les français ont
manifestement tenu a arbitré par le pays
un choix fondamental entre deux visions
opposées de l'avenir soit la division la
justice et le désordre imposé par
emmanuel macron au profit de
quelques-uns soit le rassemblement des
français autour de la justice sociale et
de la protection garantie par un cadre
fraternelle autour du lit des
millénaires de nations et de peuples
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas voté
pour emmanuel macron ont bien sûr
vocation à rejoindre ce rassemblement
je vais félicite que ce débat si
essentiel que je souhaite loyal et
respectueux puis durant ces quinze jours
se dérouler pour que le peuple français
le peuple souverain soit en mesure de
l'arbitré par son vote le 24 avril
prochain dans cette campagne j'ai décidé
d'être libre des attaches partisanes
pour être au service de tous et de
m'adresser directement à vous je
continuerai à le faire pour être si vous
le décidez au lendemain du second tour
sans exclusive aucune la présidente de
tous les français
et qui se jouera ce 24 avril n'est pas
seulement un vote de circonstances mais
un choix de société et même de
civilisation
de votre vote n'est pas en effet sur
tout le territoire français la légitime
prépondérance de la culture et de la
langue française des us et coutumes de
nos régions et des modes de vie des
français des lois et des valeurs
républicaines au premier rang desquels
la laïcité et l'égalité notamment entre
les hommes et les femmes
[Musique]
également la place que dans notre
société nous voulons donner aux
personnes face au pouvoir de l'argent je
pense par exemple à l'importance que
nous accordons à la solidarité envers
les plus vulnérables
la possibilité de jouir de droits
garantis ou encore d'accéder à la
retraite en bonne santé de votre vote du
24 avril dépendront enfin les décisions
politiques du prochain quinquennat mais
qui en réalité
engageront la france pour les 50
prochaines années la politique
migratoire sécuritaire économique
sociale énergétique européenne militaire
ou diplomatique
mon engagement sur ces sujets elle sans
fine j'assurerai l'indépendance
nationale pour faire de la france une
puissance de paix je resterai dans tous
les domaines la souveraineté de la
france c'est à dire pour les français la
liberté de décider pour eux-mêmes et de
défendre leurs intérêts je comprendrais
l'immigration elle rétablirait la
sécurité pour tous par l'écouté et
l'attention
je garantirai le respect de chacun
d'entre vous et tout particulièrement
des simples citoyens des fonctionnaires
et des élus trop souvent bafouée sous le
dernier quinquennat ces derniers mois je
vous ai présenté sans détour mais sans
aucune outrance les défis qui se posent
au pays et les solutions que je vous
propose dans le cadre d'un projet
travail est équilibré et chiffré c'est
avec le même sérieux que j'entends sans
attendre recoudre les multiples
fractures dont souffre une france trop
déchiré et qu'aucun pouvoir n'a su
jusqu'ici réparer la fracture sociale
territoriale institutionnels culturels
médical numérique je remettrai à la
france en ordre en 5 ans pour lui
permettre de prendre une place éminente
dans ce 21e siècle plein de promesses et
d'opportunités car au delà de ce
redressement nécessaire mon projet porte
en effet de grandes ambitions pour le
pays une ambition démocratique avec le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne avec
une proportionnelle pour permettre à
toutes les opinions politiques de
s'exprimer et d'être enfin représente
aberration
une ambition économique et écologique
à
[Applaudissements]
oh
une ambition économique et écologique
qui appuient le retour de la prospérité
du plein emploi sur le localisme le
patriotisme économique et le soutien à
nos tpe pme créatrices d'emplois je veux
revivifier l'esprit d'entreprise
réhabiliter la valeur travail et ré
concilier le travail et le capital par
la participation une ambition sociale
qui garantisse à tous une école du
savoir de la promotion sociale et de
l'assimilation le pouvoir d'achat des
salaires et des pensions digne un
système de santé de qualité accessible à
tous et partout un logement décent notre
pays doit s'enorgueillir de n'abandonner
aucun de ses enfants d'assurer l'égalité
la reconnaissance du mérite d'ouvrir à
chacun les voies du bonheur familial et
de l'épanouissement personnel une
ambition régaliennes enfin avec la
restauration de l'état renforcé dans ses
moyens son autorité attentif aux
conditions d'exercice matériel et moral
de ses agents un état protecteur et
juste garant des libertés de tous un
état stratège au service de la nation un
état au bon endroit toutefois mon
ambition maîtresse est d'unir les
français autour de ce grand projet
national et populaire
un projet qui fait la part belle aux
jeunes et fortifie le lien entre les
générations
un projet fédérateur pour ainsi faire à
nouveau de notre nation une communauté
de destin unis et donc invincible et de
la france un pays qui renoue avec la
prospérité et la grandeur des là présent
j'appelle tous les français de toutes
sensibilités de droite de gauche et
d'ailleurs les français de toutes
origines à rejoindre ce grand
rassemblement national et populaire
ensemble nous allons construire avec
enthousiasme et conviction
cette victoire pour mettre en oeuvre
[Applaudissements]
oms a besoin et conduire avec bonheur
notre grand pays dans le troisième
millénaire vive la république
prix la france
marine le pen qui donc veut fouetter
bien sûr ces électeurs les
23,6 maintenant qu'ils ont voté pour
elle au premier tour mais qui veut aussi
aller rassemblés parce que là c'est
l'exercice qui commande ou agrandir la
tente pour reprendre l'autre expression
politique clichés aller chercher des
électeurs qui n'ont pas voté pour elle
au premier tour son but c'est de
dépasser et sur emmanuel macron au
deuxième tour forces de redressement
espoir le président l'après je serai la
présidente de tous les français donc des
gens veut rassurer et l'anoci il dit ne
vous en faites pas j'ai compris
présidente de tous les français face au
président des riches elle a répété cette
expression là là aussi on commence à
voir le narratif s'installer le narratif
de la campagne de deuxième tour tous
ceux qui n'ont pas voté emmanuel macron
premier tour sont les bienvenus et là
elle en donne un petit peu à chacun un
petit peu à la droite si je puis dire
aux électeurs de droite elle parle de la
valeur travail vieilles valeurs
défendues par la droite et notamment par
nicolas sarkozy en son temps mais qui a
été évidemment toujours une valeur de
droite
la proportionnelle le référendum
d'initiative locale alors ça c'est pour
les électeurs mélenchon un champ
mélenchon très intéressé par une
revitalisation d'un système politique
qui objectivement est quand même plutôt
à bout de souffle il avait beaucoup fait
campagne sur un événement de la sixième
république une constituante évidemment
pas jusque là marine le pen mais elle
leur en donne un petit peu en gros il
faut évidemment qu'elle se présente
comme une présidente rassembleuse elle
dit bien je suis libre aujourd'hui de
toute attache partisane ce n'est plus la
présidente du rassemblement national qui
vous parle
c'est la future présidente de tous les
français
voilà on voit bien là et puis un petit
mot aussi parce qu'elle n'a évidemment
pas citer ni la guerre en ukraine ni
vladimir poutine mais quand même elle
qui a fait une allusion en disant j'ai
toujours été très clairs là dessus je
défendrai l'indépendance nationale c'est
pas forcément thomas cela qu'on va lui
reprocher ou
20%
avec mélenchon ce matin
il faisait beau à marseille
sur la mer fuyante
les rayons du soleil bondissait d'une
vague à l'autre ce matin
tandis que je me préparais à entrer
dans cet événement dont je ne savais
rien me sont arrivées bientôt
les échos de l'oyapock
frontière française
sur le brésil et puis ceux du maroni et
puis ceux de la martinique
et puis ceux de la guadeloupe est plus
vraiment
fidèle au premier tour
dès le premier tour
mais lisait pour leur président et j'ai
vu dans leur décision ce qu'elle
signifiait pleinement et entièrement
l'état dans lequel se trouve la patrie
et son peuple sur tous les points du
territoire un état d'exaspération et le
sentiment d'être entrées dans un état
d'urgence écologique social et
maintenant encore une fois nous le
voyons ce soir en état d'urgence
politique
car le tableau
le tableau que vous avez sous les yeux
tel qu'il a été voulue nom de notre
recette ni même du fait du peuple
français mais des institutions de la
vème république et de cette étrange
système de tirage au sort qui aboutit à
vous demander de choisir entre deux maux
dont vous sentez à la fois qu'ils sont
terribles pour vous mêmes et qu'ils ne
sont pas de même nature
et chacun d'entre vous se trouve ni au
pied du mur de sa conscience
de la décision qu'il doit prendre
c'est la condition humaine d'être sans
cesse confronté à des décisions qui sont
souvent difficiles à prendre
et bien la dernière fois que s'est il
passé
je vous ai dit ce que je vous le dirai
non
je connais votre colère mes compatriotes
vous deux ans j'ai parlé il ya quelques
instants je connais votre colère ne vous
abandonnez pas à ce qu'elle vienne à
vous faire commettre des erreurs qui
serait
définitivement irréparable
tant que la vie continue
le combat continue
chez moi devoir de vous dire qu en étant
le plus ancien d'entre vous
que la seule tâche on a à se donner
c'est celle qui accomplit le mythe de
sisyphe
lapierre retombe en bas du ravin à la
remontée
vous n'êtes plus faible du sang moyens
vous êtes en état
de mener cette bataille est la suivante
est la suivante autant qu'il y en aura
regardez voir
je n'ai jamais lâché prise je n'ai
jamais cédé je n'ai jamais blessé le
regard c'est de cette façon là que nous
avons construit cette force alors
maintenant c'est à vous de faire
dans la bataille qui arrivent nous avons
constitué le pôle populaire parce qu'ils
étaient là toutes sortes de gens ont pu
prendre appui dessus pour faire en vente
et nous a menés jusqu'à ce point
les batailles arrive devant vous
nous commettons pas l'erreur de nous
fourvoyer à peine entré sur le chemin
nous savons
pour qui nous ne voterons jamais
et pour le reste
comme je vous le dis
il ya cinq ans vous souvenez vous qu'il
ya eu quelques dégâts après notre
déclaration pour qui prendre et on les
français ils sont capables de savoir
quoi faire ils sont capables de décider
ce qui est bon pour le pays jamais nous
perdrons notre confiance dans la
démocratie dont vous ne devez pas donner
une voix à madame le pen
alors je le sais bien
je répète parce que des fois il arrive
que même quand je dis les choses c'est
comme si je ne les avais pas dit
alors je recommence à cet endroit du
film il ne faut pas donner ça le voir
madame le pen
il ne faut pas donner une seule voix
il ne faut pas donner une seule voix à
madame le pen
voilà je crois que le message qu'ont
cette partie a été entendu
alors maintenant qu'allons nous faire on
va ouvrir la page et les trois cent dix
mille personnes qui m'ont parrainer
donneront leur point de vue
ceci posé ne nous cachons pas la
violence de la déception
la violence de la déception
elle est d'abord
en pensant à tous ceux qui auraient été
entrepris et qu'il ne le sera pas
et ceci plus que le reste me cuit
ce que je me préparais à faire ce que je
croyais immédiatement à portée de main
les belles équipes dont nous disposons
et qui était prête à se déployer pour
assumer toutes les tâches il y avait à
assumer
oui c'est une déception
mais en même temps comment se cacher je
suis comme vous entre les deux comment
se cacher aussi
la cherté du travail accompli
le pôle portuaire et glee
si vous n'y étions pas
que resterait-il
pourrions nourrir et nous avons
construit ce fonds
jean luc mélenchon le grand patron chef
de la france est soumise qui avec ses 20
% de voix au premier tour
demande ainsi à ses électeurs de ne pas
commettre l'irréparable de ne pas voter
marine le pen il l'a répété quatre fois
ne votez pas une seule voix à madame le
pen il a cité camus en disant on doit
poursuivre le combat la pierre rul on la
remonte elle rôle on la remonte nous
avons construit dit-il un mouvement
et lui je vous ai dit qu'on en parle un
peu plus tôt a déjà dit qu'il ne s'était
sa dernière campagne présidentielle les
gens peuvent changer d'idée cd on a déjà
vu michel je commence avec vous le
message est clair il ne dit pas voter
macro mais il dit ne frottez pas le pen
demain le danger qui sous-tend ça c'est
dire est-ce que son électorat n'ira pas
voter restera la maison où ira voter
m'accrocher la question
c'est quand même clair que pour lui il
ya un danger de voter le pen il a dit
très très clairement donc sans dire
votez macron il a dit vous ne pouvez pas
aller de l'autre côté est bon on parlera
d'abstention plus tard entre les deux il
y avait un côté testament politique
aussi à ça parce que la crainte que
beaucoup de gens ont dû côté de monsieur
mélenchon c'est qu'une fois lui parti et
à 70 ans on peut penser que c'était
effectivement sa dernière campagne que
ça soit plus la même chose pour la
france est soumise ou l'union populaire
est ainsi que s'appelle et que ce soit
un peu compliqué il ya beaucoup de
travail à faire à gauche pour rebâtir
la gauche française mais
lorsqu'on a vu très clairement c'est que
le front républicain il s'est reformé
c'est ça qui avait battu madame le pen
66 contre 33 il ya cinq ans il faut pas
l'oublier
je pense que on peut on va pas commencer
à donner des chiffres mais le front
républicain il est reconstruit mais il
existe et je vous dis qu'ils n'ont pas
dû trouver ça très drôle oui et d'autre
part madame le pen a été obligé de dire
quand on a parlé de ses priorités elle a
commencé par la politique migratoire
ensuite il est allé à la sécurité et
ensuite elle est allée la place de la
france dans l'europe c'est les trois
choses qui vont faire hésiter certains
électeurs de l'appuyer alors ça c'est
je pense qu'elle voit déjà que il ya des
parties de son programme qui ont été
occultés au premier tour et qui pourront
pas l'être au deuxième d'ailleurs quand
on reporte les voix de zemmour sur les
voix de madame le pen on arrive à peu
près au score et l'autre nicolas dupont
aignan on arrive à part pas au score
qu'elle a eu la dernière fois c'était à
33,9 monsieur macro comme vous dites
d'une chaîne a eu 66 % des voix la
dernière fois je note aussi que
mélenchon avait fait à peu près le même
score
19,58 la dernière fois
fillon avait fait vingt la droite madame
le pen 21 et maquereau est le seul qui
fait mieux dans ce premier tour que les
autres pour l'instant on écoute
messieurs je veux avant tout m'adresser
à vous merci
merci infiniment de votre confiance de
l'espoir et de la force que vous me
donner ce soir grâce
merci mon psy
grâce grâce à vous je peux faire une
promesse je continuerai de défendre la
france et nos idées
[Applaudissements]
et
et je suis certain que bientôt nous
l'emporterons je vous remercie aussi
pour la france car je prends chacune de
vos voix comme le cri d'un peuple qui ne
veut pas mourir
le fait
le fait que vous ayez été 2 millions à
soutenir un homme parti de rien qui
n'était pas un politicien montre que mon
message a été entendu
c'est un élément fondamental qui ne
devra pas être oubliés dans les
prochains jours et dans les prochaines
années
votre voix ne pourra plus jamais être
négligée
quelle que soit l'issue du second tour
tout le monde comprendra que nos idées
valent beaucoup plus que notre score
d'aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas su convaincre assez de nos
compatriotes l'histoire dira et dira
pourquoi nous ne sommes pas parvenus
alors qu'une majorité de français
partage nos inquiétudes et nos espoirs
peut-être en raison de l'absence de
campagnes et de débats peut-être en
raison du traitement qui nous a été
réservé de la situation internationale
et peut-être aussi simplement par ma
faute
[Applaudissements]
merci bien sûr j'ai commis des erreurs
je veux dire que je les assume tout j'en
porte l'entière responsabilité
je dois beaucoup de mes succès à mon
équipe je ne leur doit aucun de mes
échecs mais à la fin de cette campagne
mais à la fin de cette campagne j'ai la
fierté de ne pas être devenu un
politicien je n'ai jamais menti pour
gagner un point dans les sondages je
n'ai jamais travesti ma pensée et je
n'ai jamais trahi
dans les jours qui viennent
vous allez entendre tout le monde vous
expliquer ce que nous avons raté
moi je veux donc vous dire tout ce que
nous avons réussi
je veux dire à ces millions de français
grâce à vous rien ne sera plus jamais
comme avant
je vous demande de rester digne de
rester fort de garder la foi vous avez
été admirable pendant cette campagne
votre vote est un vote pionniers c'est
un vote d'avenir c'est un vote d'espoir
car les vérités que nous avons dit à la
france pendant cette campagne
s'imposeront à tous dans les années qui
viennent
je veux
je veux remercier du fond du coeur tous
ceux qui m'ont aidé à toute mon équipe à
tous nos militants jeudi un immense
merci
votre énergie votre ferveur
votre grandeur d'âme votre générosité
votre organisation ont impressionné la
france toute entière
je me souviens encore du mois de mai
dernier à l'époque nous n'étions qu'une
dizaine
ce n'était qu'une idée nous constations
le blocage de la vie politique française
nous constations l'état déplorable de la
france et des vieux partis à bout de
souffle nous ne savions pas quel accueil
les français nous réserverai mais nous
étions convaincus qu'il était de notre
devoir de nous lever
je me suis levé
un an plus tard
nous voici finalement face au duel qui
était annoncé depuis 2010 est alors si
électoralement rien ne change
politiquement tout a changé tout a
changé parce que nous sommes arrivés
nous avons fait irruption dans la vie
politique et regardez nous avons dépassé
les vieux parti moribond nous avons fait
en trois mois ce qu'aucun politicien n'a
jamais réussi en 15 ans nous avons
construit le plus grand parti de france
à mes côtés une jeunesse s'est levée
cette jeunesse c'est l'interdiction de
désespérer car elle ne disparaîtra pas
les drapeaux qui ont flotté au trocadéro
ne s'abaisseront plus jamais
alors
alors oui nous sommes déçus
mais nous avons gagné dans cette
campagne quelque chose qui n'a pas de
prix la puissance et l'expérience je
vous le dis chez reconquête nous sommes
puissants nous sommes forts nous avons
des militants présents dans toute la
france nous avons d intelligence
redoutable des compétences inégalées
nous nous projetons déjà vers l'avenir
je ne m'en tiendrais pas là car conquête
n'abandonnera rien tant que la france ne
sera pas reconquise
notre ligne à sa singularité et elle
n'est représenté nulle part ailleurs
nous sommes les seuls à défendre notre
civilisation et notre identité dans la
culture à l'école dans la rue dans nos
moeurs dans notre vision de l'écologie
de la politique de la société nous
sommes les seuls à vouloir réconcilier
le peuple et les élites les salariés et
les patrons les gilet jaune et la manif
pour tous les abstentionnistes et la
politique je suis déterminé à poursuivre
le combat avec tous ceux qui sont à mes
côtés tous ceux qui nous rejoindrons
dans les semaines à venir et je vous
dirai très vite la forme que prendra
notre action je veux dire pour finir
parce que je pense à la france avant
tout parce que c'était tout le sens de
ma candidature que je ne peux pas rester
les bras croisés devant les mots qui
guette notre pays j'ai bien des
désaccords avec marine le pen je les ai
abordés pendant cette campagne je n'en
referai pas la liste mais il y à face à
marine le pen un homme qui a fait entrer
deux millions d'immigrés un homme qui
n'a pas dit un mot d'identité de
sécurité d'immigration pendant sa
campagne et qui fera donc pire s'il
était réélu
je ne me tromperai pas d'adversaires
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'appelle
mes électeurs à voter pour marine le pen
alors voilà eric zemmour sans surprise
qui m'a d'abord dit qu'il veut continuer
son combat le cri d'un peuple qui ne
veut pas mourir at il dit or il vient de
dire c'est pour ça que c'est un peu long
où vous voulez entendre qu avec quels
mots il allait choisir il est très clair
il invite ses partisans ses électeurs à
voter pour marine le pen j'ai beaucoup
de désaccords avec elle mais pas au
point de voter pour macron qui a fait
entrer deux millions d'immigrants en
france donc voilà les sept pour sa de
monsieur et vous aussi tenter que tout
le monde va aller voter
de façon cohérente on le disait plus tôt
vont voter marine le pen mais c'est
insuffisant elle a besoin d'élargir à la
besoin d'aller chercher d'autres appuis
raphaël bouvier au clair vous êtes en
direct du rassemblement des manuels
macron à paris on attend son discours on
disait tout à l'heure soupir de
soulagement quand même et on le voit la
plus on regarde les mathématiques plus
les choses se présentent quand même
assez bien pour lui
et d'ailleurs quand on tentait entre nos
interventions de parler à des partisans
d' emmanuel macron nous attendait là on
écoute ce que ceux en dix-sept candidats
candidate est en train de dire parce
qu'on voulait savoir quelle à elle la
ligne l'instruction donnée aux partisans
de chacun des candidats et il y en a
beaucoup effectivement qui ont appelé à
voter pour emmanuel macron encore à ne
pas voter pour mairie comme c'est le cas
sur le troisième candidat jean-luc
mélenchon à ce sont des déclarations qui
ont été applaudis par des manuels mâcon
qui voit effectivement les chiffres qui
leur sont plutôt favorables en ce moment
mais les militants à les bénévoles les
politiciens qui j'ai parlé dans cette
salle les sabres qui ne doivent pas
tenir la réélection du président acquise
il ya des défis qui sont devant eux des
défis qui ont été illustrés au cours des
derniers jours quand on a vu les courbes
se resserrer ya une certaine nervosité
au sein de l'entourage de manuel macro
alors là il faut que le candidat soit
plus présent sur le terrain vous savez
que ses adversaires certains de ses
partisans lui ont reproché aussi de ne
peut être pas s'être consacré
suffisamment cette campagne alors je
parlais politiciens qui me disent il
faut le voir du nord au sud de l'est à
l'ouest de la france au cours des deux
prochaines semaines être très présent se
préparer pour le débat de l'entre-deux
tours alors lui il ya ces appel au
ralliement qui ont été lancés par des
politiciens mise à part évidemment eric
zemmour qui lui appelle à voter pour
marine le pen mais il ya quand même le
risque d'abstention aussi cet électorat
parce qu'il faut savoir qu'il ya quand
même au sein des lectorats d'autres
partis par exemple chez les écologistes
et encore plus chez les militants de la
france est soumise de jean-luc mélenchon
une satisfaction à l'endroit du
quinquennat des manuels seront par
exemple sur les enjeux climat
environnementaux sociaux alors il faut
convaincre ces gens là de se déplacer le
jour du vote au deuxième tour le 24
avril parlant de déplacement vous
attendez monsieur macron à quelques
minutes
exactement emmanuel macron qui a donc
suivi cette soirée à l'elysée qui s'est
déplacé ici donc à la porte de
versailles dans tout centre de
conférences on a entendu un peu près
tous les candidats on doit venir sur
cette scène qui est derrière nous et le
tour est prévu dans les prochaines
minutes et doit s'adresser à ses
militants on va suivre avec attention
évidemment ce qui va leur dire peut-être
donnera t des signaux des indices sur la
direction que prendra sa campagne pour
les deux prochaines semaines pour le
deuxième pays et vous nous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est une date que jean cercle
et le 20 avril le débat ça c'est une
union ou fait beaucoup de débats on
connaît les débats sur un débat à 2
c ils prennent le temps de débattre de
toutes les questions donc ce sera le 20
avril prochain et le deuxième tour pour
les gens qui nous écoutent ce je le
rappelle c'est le 24 dans deux semaines
très exactement à tout de suite rafael a
tout de suite
je le disais en 6 et des mathématiques
un premier tour un deuxième tour puis
c'est des probabilités de deux reports
de voix il faut quand même souligner qu
emmanuel macron a mieux fait c'est le
seul qui a mieux fait dans le premier
tour là par rapport au premier tour la
dernière fois et il avait fini avec
66% des voix contre marine le pen 33 est
ce que vous croyez que le le bassin de
l'extrême droite reste plafonné à peu
près ça 33 34% parce qu'en fait les
électeurs d'extrême droite sont quand
même des électeurs qui vont voter
facilement généralement ils sont très
mobilisés donc c'est pour ça que les
réserves de voix chez les
abstentionnistes ne sont pas très très
forte dans dans ce groupe électorale là
parce qu'ils sont très motivés donc ils
vont aux urnes donc pour l'instant
statistiquement on peut presque
qu'additionner les scores effectivement
de marine le pen d'eric zemmour et de la
haie et de nicolas dupont aignan on
disait qu'il y avait convergence parfois
avec une certaine frange l'électorat de
jean luc mélenchon sur délais les plus
radicaux les acteurs s'il a été très
clair exactement mais l'un
d'eux dit ne pas une seule voix à marine
le pen mais il ne dit pas allés voter
pour autant il dit ne votez pas pour
marine le pen mais il dit peut-être il
peut encourager d'une certaine cote est
l'abstention d'un de ses électeurs on a
vu quand même que les mots sont
importants eric zemmour dix personnes
dans cette campagne n'a parlé de
défendre la civilisation défendre
l'identité à lacune dans la culture à
l'école et c'est exactement ce que
marine le pen a fait dans son discours
quand on dit que le ton change entre les
deux tours c'est ça marine le pen a déjà
un stylet dans son discours la de de
qualification pour le deuxième tour des
éléments de ce que va être sa campagne
dans les prochains jours parce qu'elle
l'a dit nous devons aller parler
d'identité nous devons parler
d'immigration chose qu'elle a totalement
escamoté pendant les premières semaines
hélène un mot sur eric zemmour qu'on a
attendu plutôt bon il dit vouloir
continuer le combat on verra quelle
forme tout ça va prendre lui
même s'ils avaient un report total
mathématiques ce n'est pas suffisant
pour madame le pen mais c'était clair
qu'il allait amener ses électeurs de son
mouvement vers le pain bien sûr c'était
clair parce qu'on l'a dit depuis le
départ ils ont un socle de valeurs et
d'idées communes donc ça ça ne faisait
pas de doute maintenant l'histoire est
très différente pour eric zemmour il a
commencé sa campagne
si suis moi en imposant sa thématique de
campagne et puis en partant très très
haut et puis on le disait tout à l'heure
avec des soutiens qui venait qui
quittent et marine le pen pour venir
dans son dans son camp et quand bien
même il ne se voyait pas forcément
président de la république à l'issue du
second tour le 24 avril il se
positionnait déjà comme chef de la
future union des droites aujourd'hui
l'histoire elle est très très différent
que ce soir pour eric zemmour
7% des voix ce n'est pas si mauvais pour
quelqu'un qui de fait vient d'entrer en
politique donc ce n'est pas un échec
total mais il est évidemment bien loin
des 23 23 5% de marine le pen qui quand
bien même elle ne serait pas élu au
second tour dans quinze jours restera
évidemment la personne centrale de la
droite nationale identitaire et donc
eric zemmour oui veut continuer il a dit
qu'il serait candidat aux législatives
il sera peut-être députés mais
aujourd'hui la grande gagnante de cette
famille là ça reste marine le pen
oui très bien années que à qui on peut
parler à paris dans le cas de madame le
pen alors c'est intéressant parce que
annick
oui encore une fois on n'est pas en
train de dire que ce n'est plus possible
du tout mais le chemin pour la victoire
au deuxième tour est difficile et semé
d'embûches
quel esprit vous êtes quelle atmosphère
vous êtes vous pouvez nous décrire dans
le cas de marine le pen
mais voilà vous l'avez dit patrice
plusieurs à qui on a parlé nous a dit
nous on dit ça apporte ce ne sera pas
facile ça va être difficile c'est une
nouvelle bataille qui commence toujours
à convaincre qu'ils ont entendu leur
candidate a lancé un appel à tous les
français de tous les
de toutes les origines de toutes les
sensibilités politiques lors qu'il dise
ça sera pas facile parce que eux aussi
ont fait des calculs et une cale kamer
ici quand eric zemmour du parti
reconquête a appelé sans équivoque à
voter pour marine le pen mais ils ont
noté aussi que plusieurs candidats se
sont succédé pour dire que pour faire
barrage à l'extrême droite alors que
marine le pen dans son discours au vu de
ces premières phrases c'était on appelle
tous ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour une
manuelle macron à se joindre à nous à
moi pour ce projet pour la france donc
mène encore aux patriotes cours et je
peux vous citer quelques unes ce qu'elle
était en train elle dit pour redonner la
liberté ou français elle veut être la
présidente de tous elle dit que le 24
avril lors du second tour en vol libre
des décisions qui vont avoir un impact
pour la france pas seulement prendre un
canapé pendant les 50 prochaines années
dont quelle bulle elle recoudre ce
qu'elle ait fait la facture de la
facture en france à plusieurs
j'ai un hymne au social médical
politique donc un ebel vraiment pourra
sauver mais ici vous aviez après le
soulagement certaines missions de
soulager la cub on est au 2e tour d'eau
disent on était convaincu qu'elle le
ferait d'autres disent aussi va ça va
être beaucoup plus difficile qu'on le
pensait on est aussi que l'écart est
peut-être nous diront qu'en 2017 et
durabilité mais plusieurs disent oh on
se relève les manches pour c'est une
nouvelle bataille est une nouvelle
campagne mais on sent de l'inquiétude
vraiment j'ai entendu à plusieurs
reprises ce sera pas facile et quand bon
c'est pas tout le monde veut nous parler
non plus parce qu on est déjà en train
de faire des calculs on voit des gens
qui paraît des 10 secondes et déjà
stratégie mais on sent sur un mélange de
financement de son heureux mais aussi
bon l'homme maintenant une nouvelle
bataille commence elle sera peut-être
plus rude puisque les attentes après la
dynamique du premier tour oui parce que
vous avez raison de souligner un et qui
avec trois points en 2017 qui les
séparaient au premier tour il ya cinq
points ce soir alors
il est
chaque point il faut arracher au
deuxième tour foa fois les
augmenter ses appuis ma grand en a ne
serait ce que ces chefs des autres on
les a vus mélenchon était plus clair en
moi je me trompe il a été plus clair
cette fois ci la dernière fois encore
indien ne fait pas une erreur
irréparable en votant le pen l'a donc
déjà ça donne le ton à ce barrage
républicain dont parle m celle ci
dessous talât qui s'étaient levés à
l'époque contre le père est là
maintenant contre la fille
là voilà mais vous savez ici certains
militants essaient de se consoler en
disant mais d'échec français émettre
leurs propres yeux donc des consignes
qui viennent de divers candidats eh bien
nous on essaie de ne pas trop s'en faire
mais en dix ans on sent qu'ils s'en font
but surtout quand certains pensaient
peut-être que peut-être bien % peut-être
b 5 % des militants de les partisans de
jean-luc mélenchon pourrait aller dans
le camp de marine le pen parce que ce
sont des patriotes sur des nationalistes
mais s'ils écoutent la voix de leur chef
de l'union populaire il est saoul jean
luc mélenchon et bien peut-être que ce
transfert de voix là ne se réalisera pas
donc c'est pour ça que déjà on dit la
bataille le poids commencer demain avec
alcool a commencé ce soir
un petit mot avant de vous laisser aller
qu'on va parler roland lescure dans une
seconde que l'on connaît bien que
travailler à la caisse ici
financier qui député des français
établis hors de france bon mais un petit
mot sur ces gens qui avaient quitté
madame le pen qui avait claqué la porte
pour aller avec zemmour de la nièce de
madame le pen d'autres il y avait des
figures importantes du mouvement le pen
là elle tue machine elle veut rassembler
mais je magie noire des lendemains
difficiles pour ces gens là
oui peut être difficile parce que c'est
rappelez vous sa vieillesse
marion maréchal qui a laissé tomber le
le pen d'ailleurs parce que quand même
il ya quelques années il y avait un
froid entre la nièce de la tante qu'elle
soit allée se joindre à eric zemmour ça
avait l'air plus doux baiser de la mort
sauf que bon on l'avait entendu un peu
et pleurer éplorée dire qu'elle avait un
peu élevé marion tout ça est donc à quel
point on pourra se rabibocher avec la
nièce et c'était déjà pas de l'amour où
semble-t-il avant cherché ribéry son
parti alors voilà on verra ce qui se dit
comment de quoi les lendemains seront
faits le côté et réconciliation est ce
que c'est possible mais on disait en
même temps du côté du rassemblement que
le départ de certains éléments ça
pourrait peut-être aider marine le pen à
se recentrer à dédiaboliser encore plus
son parti maintenant peut-être qu'elle a
besoin de ces voix-là très bien nick
allez voir comment on réagit autour de
vous on ira vous retrouver merci
beaucoup roland lescure donc député des
français établis hors de france et porte
parole de la république en marche vous
êtes monsieur lescure bonjour d'abord
vous êtes tous être vous à être vous ici
ou et vous êtes à paris eh bien je suis
entre les deux j'étais à montréal
jusqu'à hier puisque j ai voté sous la
pluie à vous alors oui
oui oui ça a été un peu compliqué donc
j'en profite pour saluer toutes les
électrices et les électeurs qui ont fait
l'effort d'aller voter j'arrive beaucoup
c'est vrai que c'était un peu compliqué
mais voilà je suis rentré dans la nuit
je me voici de retour à paris pour
commenter ses résultats pour vous et
pour les autres ici mais on apprécie que
vous soyez là monsieur lescure première
question que jamais les chiffres est-ce
que monsieur macron est en meilleure
posture aujourd'hui qu'il ne l'était en
écoutez c'est très difficile vraiment un
nouveau match qui commence là donc le
second tour d'abord parce que les
clivages traditionnels ont disparu la
droite la gauche sont laminés à les
partis traditionnels du gouvernement au
moins 2 5% donc il reste un électorat
assez diffus qui va devoir se
positionner entre deux offres très très
différentes on peut espérer vous l'avez
begin seconde que monsieur macro ayant
un peu plus au premier tour que la
dernière fois l'écart par rapport à
marine le pen ce point que mieux placé
on a eu une participation importante ça
ça nous faisait peur on a trois français
sur quatre voter on avait peur que ce
soit moi mais vraiment c'est un nouveau
match qui commence maintenant il va
falloir convaincre comment le combattre
1 les gens qui n'ont pas voté pour nous
d'aller voter évidemment d'aller voter
pour emmanuel macron aidez nous à
comprendre monsieur lescure vous
connaissez bien
la politique française ce qui est en
train de se passer cette déconstruction
vous l'avais dit la droite
traditionnelle
madame pécresse à 4,8 pour salah n'a
même pas à la pause 8 l'a4 pour ça
les socialistes madame hidalgo et à 2%
donc et ils sortent du radar
complètement est ce que c'est un moment
vers autre chose vers un autre ordre est
ce que la gauche va se remet est ce que
le mouvement mélenchon va être la base
comment vous voyez les plaques
tectoniques de la politique française
mais si c'est une réplique pour
reprendre votre expression
empruntée des vocabulaires des
tremblements de terre c'est une réplique
de la secousse de 2017 c'est à dire
qu'en 2017 des gens emmanuel macron
était entrée dans le paysage politique
français par le centre en écartant les
partis traditionnels et là on est une
réplique par les extrêmes où l'extrême
droite et l'extrême gauche continue de
renier les partis traditionnels qui au
fond ne nous en vouloir qu'à eux mêmes
ils avaient perdu la cohérence
idéologique historique qui était la leur
ils sont extrêmement divisé entre des
partis pro-européens et des partis - pro
européenne voire même parfois anti
européenne
finalement les électeurs ont choisi
d'aller vers des visions très tranché
monsieur macron et 100% européen aux
grossistes libéral démocrate et on a
deux parties au movie deux candidats
d'extrême droite et d'extrême gauche je
ne l'aimais pas dans un même sac
évidemment marine le pen
extrêmement traditionnel
anti-immigration anti européenne et
monsieur mélenchon qui fait des
critiques recevable du capitalisme et
qui propose des solutions d'hier ou
d'avant-hier mais qui a identifié par
exemple la cause idéologique comme une
cause importante de monsieur mélenchon a
réussi avec succès à parler à des jeunes
ok partis traditionnels sont laminés il
reste aujourd'hui trois offres
politiques la nôtre celle de monsieur
mélenchon celle de madame le pen est ce
que ça va durer ou est-ce qu'au fond
c'est une étape de plus vers une
construction d'autres choses je pense
que les semaines qui viennent puis les
cinq années qui suivent vont en décider
et tant que votre président monsieur
macron restent au centre et centre large
gauche droite et vous êtes il ne reste
que deux places pour les extrêmes en
fait là il faudrait que métro parc pour
qu'on retrouve un autre équilibre
bon ça viendra un jour un serpent sous
les deux mandats pas plus mais les noms
mais j'espère surtout que ma rester dans
une composition future des forces
politiques autour de forces
progressistes c'est à dire que la colère
qui s'exprime dans les votes de madame
le pen c'est sûr et dans une partie des
votes mélenchon il faut qu'on arrive à
la tombe t il faut qu'on arrive à la
calmer ça même si on a eu des bons
résultats économiques pour lorsqu'un
canard comment ces cinq années il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin vous visez
plein emploi il faut pour redonner
espoir aux gens on sort une crise
sanitaire économique et maintenant
militaires historiques l'objet c'est de
redonner espoir à des gens qui sont en
colère qui sont déçus et ça c'est pas
facile vous le savez ces métiers ces
mouvements sont extrêmement puissants
aux etats unis ils ont été puissant au
royaume uni y sont évidemment éminemment
puis sont aux portes de l'europe
aujourd'hui où monsieur poutine est en
guerre à l'oreille et l'ukraine en
hongrie en pologne etc etc on fait
vraiment faim c'est un mouvement
historique très fort on a heureusement
un leader en france qui est heures je
pense
progressiste démocrate est assez fort
mais le défi les cinq ans qui viennent
ça va être le combat de la colère est
mauvaise conseillère et que c'est plutôt
dans l'optimisme est dans le pragmatisme
on va réussir à progresser mais croyez
moi pour être régulièrement l'objet d'
insulte sur les réseaux sociaux dit bell
incendiaires c'est pas tous les jours
facile et est ce que monsieur mac rang
face à cette colère l'ajustement dont
vous parlez qu'exige chez vous qui
existe aux états unis qui sait si roux
le voit devra pas descendre plus souvent
de jupiter la paix à l'est sur la terre
peut y aller
faire face avec pragmatisme justement à
ces problèmes que soulèvent les français
oui alors il l'a fait plus que spawn
rien reprocher c'est vrai que début de
mandat a peut-être été un peu jupitérien
que vous venez de le dire mais à partir
de la crise des gilets jaunes il a
compris qui devrait ce qui devrait se
contenter votre français beaucoup plus
il a organisé un grand débat national
qui m'a un peu rappelé là vous savez la
commission bouchard taylor au québec sur
sur un hors jeu très particulier lui l'a
fait de manière très large il a fait
plein de réunions publiques et nous a
engagés nous à faire aussi et ça a été
extrêmement efficace il a fait une
campagne trop court malheureusement mais
une campagne au plus près du terrain et
dans les deux semaines qui viennent il
va devoir le faire à nouveau et vous
avez raison le le deuxième quinquennat
sera un quinquennat des changes de
débats et de contact avec la population
roland lescure avant de vous laisser
aller
quels sont les écueils là dans les deux
prochaines semaines pour votre camp pour
monsieur mac rompre parce que le danger
c'est de se dire c'est dans le sac les
mathématiques sont de notre côté
mélenchon enfin appel pour monsieur
macron très sentie
il faut qu'il fasse campagne comme vous
êtes quand même c'est pas c'est pas
réglé ce n'est pas décidé d'avancer non
et puis il faut surtout arriver à faire
campagne pour c'est à dire que en 2002
monsieur chirac s'est retrouvé tout seul
face à le pen élue à 80 % des voix parce
que les gens ne voulaient pas me le pen
là on a vraiment besoin de convaincre
les gens qu'il faut voter pour évaluer
le maquereau évidemment faire obstacle à
la politique délétère de madame le pen
mais aussi et surtout voté pour et voter
tout simplement le risque c'est
l'abstention une fois de plus ce risque
ne s'est pas avérée pour ce premier tour
va croiser les doigts et tout faire pour
que dans ce second tour les gens aient
voté aussi y compris à montréal s'engage
vraiment toutes les françaises et les
français malgré les difficultés d'hier
voici de régler ça pour le second tour à
allez hop et oui c'est un peu l'homme
comme vous savez
mais bon quand même le droit d'aller
voter c'est quand même important très
bien monsieur est ce que vous
personnellement est-ce que vous souhaité
avoir un autre rôle dans un éventuel
verdict et on verra moi je
non mais vraiment je me concentre sur la
réélection des médias la tenue
d'élections française c'est une élection
à 4 tours il ya d'abord les deux tours
de la présidentielle
on fait tout pour qu'il soit réélu et
très vite après la présidentielle je
déciderai ou non si je demande un autre
mandat aux électeurs d'amérique du nord
j'ai eu vraiment cinq ans absolument
exceptionnel vous l'avais dit je venais
d'une expérience fantastique à la caisse
de dépôt je vraiment je mesure tout le
tout le bonheur que bouffer les
électeurs mais en m'élisant les chaque
chose en son temps on se reparle si vous
voulez 10 cl de lait tous semaine deux
semaines et demie et je vais en soutane
et oui le rendez vous est pris pour le
24 c'est sûr
pour le deuxième tour ces prix là c'est
toujours intéressant vous parlez vous
est d'une clarté absolue
merci au revoir à lescure député des
français établis hors de france et
peut-être un jour un autre un autre
pause responsabilité c'est évidemment
monsieur macron reste au pouvoir ce qui
est quand même mieux parti pour lui à
cette heure-ci que ce matin qu en a
parlé c'est vrai sauf qu'il ya quand
même un nouveau match qui commence pour
lescure le le rappeler un match où
forcément le président de la république
candidat va devoir faire campagne pour
devrait changer de braquet roland
lescure disait il faut voter pour bon
bah peut-être que ça va être l'occasion
pour le candidat mac ronde donner un
petit peu plus de propositions aussi
parce que ce qu'on lui a beaucoup
reproché pendant cette première partie
de campagne c'est finalement de ne pas
voir beaucoup de chose de neuf à mettre
sur la table retraite à 65 ans bon quand
on est déjà à la retraite en général ça
plaît et c'est bien pour ça que les
retraités font partie de son électorat
quand on est jeune c'est pas sûr qu'on
soit totalement
voilà en faveur de sa donc sûrement
qu'il va gauchisé un petit peu son
discours pour parler aussi à tous ces
électeurs même s'ils ne sont pas si
nombreux de yannick jadot 2
d'anne hidalgo qui sont en déshérence et
à qui on dit aujourd'hui il faut faire
barrage à madame le pen il faut voter
macro pas là qu'on voit que pardonnez
moi hélène c'est la voiture je macron
les français ont commencé il ya de
nombreuses années à faire ça sira 95
agir à 95 qu'on avait recréé nous ici
dans une émission électorale ya
longtemps j'avais vu ça m'avait
impressionné comme un caméra avec sur
une moto est relié à un satellite et
comme au tour de france retour de flamme
aussi examen alors voilà c'est l'arrivée
de d'emmanuel macron qui va aller parler
comme vous êtes qui il ya tout intérêt à
se retourner vers sa gauche apple
puisque à sa droite il ya moins de monde
et il ya moins de monde et puis on voit
bien que là le gros réservoir de voix à
l'orias légal et un petit peu les
socialistes un petit peu d'économistes
un petit peu les écologistes et puis
hier jean luc mélenchon il y à ces
électeurs là qui n'ont pas grand chose à
voir donc eux il faut leur parler aussi
faut leur parler rénovation de la vie
politique il y sont attachés il faut
parler évidemment enjeux de pouvoir
d'achat il faut leur parler climat enfin
crise climatique ce qui pour l'instant
n'a intéressé personne mais les
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon ça les
intéresse et donc il va falloir vraiment
qu emmanuel macron candidats deuxième
tour certes sûrement beaucoup mieux
placé qu'il ne pouvait l'espérer ce
matin même encore et bien descendre dans
l'arène et puis et puis il va avoir à
affronter évidemment marine le pen lan
duel lors du débat là aussi il faudra se
méfier parce qu'il avait il l'avait
largement dominé lors du premier débat
entre deux ans en 2017
là d'abord elle sera mieux préparée à
n'en pas douter et puis forcément tous
les petits points qu'elle va marquer on
va se dire ah oui finalement à lézarder
attend exactement des attentes
différentes
quand exactement les vieux généraux
disent toujours on ne refait jamais la
même bataille fait même une bataille
remportée donc lui devra trouver ou six
autres choses il ne peut pas la prendre
de haut de la même façon comme il
l'avait fait et il a un bilan à défendre
aussi ce qui est très différent
évidemment de la dernière fois en 2010
est donc évidemment c'est beaucoup de
points sur lesquels marine le pen va
appuyer puis quand on disait tout à
l'heure que dans cette campagne d'entre
deux tours il faut d'abord parler aux
électeurs qui n'ont pas voté pour nous
un marine le pen l'a fait déjà avec les
électeurs d'eric zemmour en disant je
vais parler de civilisation je veux
parler de la culture de la france etc
elle parle aussi à ceux qui n'ont pas
voté pour emmanuel macron et ceux qui
rejettent les mesures qu'il est qu'il
propose dans son programme ou par lee
helen de la la retraite à 65 ans eh bien
elle elle propose de ne pas reculer
l'âge de départ à la retraite donc là
elle va aller chercher ceux qui n'ont
pas voté pour un poème et mâcon elle
parle du pouvoir de l'argent donc
évidemment là elle s'inscrit encore dans
sa lignée de la grande défenseuse du
pouvoir d'achat et et ça effectivement
notamment accéder à la retraite en bonne
santé le rsa le rsa c'est une
proposition des macros qui est
intéressante du point de vue politique
en tout cas dans la joute qui va y avoir
entre les deux parce que lui veut
conditionner leurs revenus si le revenu
de solidarité active qui est un revenu
minimum un minimum d'activités bien-être
social exactement elle dit qu'il faut
être beaucoup plus solidaires avec les
plus vulnérables dont qu'elle veut
essentiellement allait vraiment
s'accrocher à cette base de l'électorat
acquis et qui évidemment a du mal à
joindre les deux bouts à la fin du mois
et qui n'auraient pas voté pour un point
d'un wagon qui était peut-être réfugier
dans un historique chez elle faisait
mouche et jean luc mélenchon et donc on
va y avoir sept cette dynamique là à
étudier ce mot dynamique est là nous
l'avait employé à plusieurs reprises
elle est très forte en ce moment en
faveur d' emmanuel macron parce qu'avec
cinq points d'écart effectivement sur
marine le pen ça lui donne un élan pour
cette c2 semaine d'entre deux tours que
peut-être il
ne soupçonnait pas effectivement en
arrivant devant l'urne michel c'est
roger le
monsieur lescure a dit un certain nombre
de choses intéressantes quand même oui
doit descend plus votre texte matin-là
sur jupiter il doit redescendre plus
souvent il doit accélérer il doit faire
face comme beaucoup de présidents deux
premiers ministres sur la planète à
cette colère à 7
à cette idée que la mondialisation a
fait des gagnants mais a fait trop de
perdants justement
l'inégalité de tout ça donc on doit il
doit faire des efforts dans ce sens là
il doit faire il doit faire des efforts
surtout à sa gauche comme vous disiez il
reste plus grand chose à droite pour lui
mais il avait commencé à faire ça dans
l'unique meeting qu'il a fait dans sa
campagne il y avait ouvert des choses
vers la gauche surtout vers la loge dont
il a gardé des choses qui sont pas
populaires à gauche comme la retraite à
65 ans mais il avait ouvert beaucoup
là-dessus entre autres sur l'éducation
des choses comme ça je vais revenir sur
une chose on le disait beaucoup au début
de la campagne qui les aident personne
de monsieur mac on le disait tout ça
c'est une stratégie pour qu'il se
retrouve face à face avec le pen au
deuxième tour puis que ce soit facile
c'est la stratégie qui a fonctionné là
on le voit ce soir et probablement qu'il
a eu déjà des voix de jacky normalement
serait allé plus à gauche et qui ont dit
mais mon parti sera vendu une part je
vais aller tout de suite chez makro et
pour ses parts il a écouté les
écologistes des communistes et
socialistes et les républicains ont sous
les 5% des voix donc leurs dépenses
électorales ne sont pas remboursés on
parlait au québec date perdre sont des
pôles pour ces parties là c'est énorme
parce que même si on fait une
campagne qui est qui qui a pas de
résultats c'est les coûts d'une campagne
nationale en france sont énormes ça va
peser lourd ça dans la reconstruction de
chacun de ses mouvements
alors parce que
l'argent pousse pression des arbres puis
on donne pas beaucoup d'argent quelqu'un
de mission ils sont tant ils sont sous
le respirateur artificiel c'est parti la
mouche est l'auteur les secours le
résumait bien macron appris le centre il
reste les deux extrêmes une gauche à
droite puis le reste c'est des
grenailles s'est littéralement des
grenats est-ce que ça va renaître tout
savoir tout ça va se
reconstruire une fois macron partie si
tenté qu'il est réélu à voir mais ça
change il ya plus il ya plus de spa et à
plus d espace à gauche pour reconstruire
avec le vrai pour sa de mélenchon que à
droite ou de toute évidence et la droite
c'est devenu l'extrême droite par grande
partie en france voilà voilà c'est le
pen et zemmour font font 30 30 30 30
exactement
hélène
pendant qu'on a vu mesdames et messieurs
monsieur macron c'est loin ils parlent
où il part de l'elysée il sera versé par
si je dois est de paris
porte de versailles
c'est loin très bien vous attendez à
quoi comme discours cela quelques
minutes je m'attends à ce qu'ils donnent
des signes ce qu'il donne des signes à
tous les électeurs évidemment qui
pourraient le rejoindre michel venait de
viens de le dire plus tellement
d'électeurs à droite qui peuvent venir
le rejoindre parce que tout simplement
aimé ils ont déjà voté pour macron
premier tour donc cela ils sont acquis
en quelque sorte donc aujourd'hui ce
soir il faut parler aux autres et puis
aux abstentionnistes malgré tout parce
que y'en a quand même on dit au
finalement l'abstention c'est pas
terrible oui enfin il ya quand même
encore 25 % de gens qui ne se sont pas
déplacés ce qui n'est pas totalement
rien donc les électeurs de gauche les
abstentionnistes cela il faut leur dire
quelque chose leur dire qu'on a entendu
leur colère lawrence cannon ancien
ministre conservateur qu'on connaît bien
ancien ambassadeur du canada en france
je vous rappelle monsieur qu'il n'y a
pas d'ambassadeur du canada en france
laurence depuis
on attend de nomination de monsieur
trudeau ce cannon bonsoir bonsoir alors
premières réflexions
que je le disais tout à l'heure ce une
élection qui nous concerne tous parce
que ça soit mc ren ou le pen ça change
pas mal de choses sur la planète et
aussi pour le canada
tout à fait est d'autant plus d'autant
plus d'un membre du g7 d'un membre de
l'otan je pense qu'on a rappelé à tous
les spectateurs donc pour le canada
c'est un partenaire essentiel
imaginez deux secondes patrie si nous
n'avions pas d'ambassadeur aux états
unis si nous n'avions pas d'ambassade
rage en grande bretagne en italie
et que ça sèche le japon et c est donc
ce sont des choses qui malheureusement
sont très tristes de paume au canada et
parfois je me demande si c'est en
principe nous ment on nous prend
vraiment au sérieux c'est triste ce qui
se déroule le canada dit vous paie le
prix fort de ne pas être représenté à
paris
on a évidemment le canada a une
ambassade
on a des fonctions qui sont des
fonctions reuilly
relations entre le canada et la france
mais plus important quand c'est cette
relation particulière entre ce qu'un
ambassadeur peut établir avec des déjà
politique avec les autorités de haut
niveau au gouvernement ça c'est des
informations ça c'est des liens
privilégie que l'ambassadeur peut avoir
avec non seulement les autorités
françaises mais également
avec d'autres ambassadeurs qui sont en
poste en france alors tout ça ça joue
beaucoup ça joue énormément dans la
relation et j'ajouterais finalement que
ce qui est très bien vu c'est un
ambassadeur qui a l'oreille du premier
ministre du canada de la même manière
qu'eux savent et patrice vous avez passé
un bon bout de temps ici à ottawa c'est
extrêmement important pour les canadiens
de sa mort
l'ambassadeur américain par exemple à
l'oreille une résident les états unis
alors vous voyez on peut avoir des
relations mais on peut avoir des
relations améliorées et je pense que
c'est avec un ambassadeur qu'on peut
avoir une relation encore mieux pour les
intérêts du pays et on verra le 24 avril
mais si jamais il devait avoir un
changement de régime important avec
madame le pen d'autant c'est d'autant
plus important d'être pas loin pour les
premiers contacts pour pour être sûr de
tirer son épingle du jeu
une pratique qui était une pratique
jusqu'à jusqu'à tout récemment qui
étaient respectés en tout cas c'était de
dire on va changer l'ambassadeur du
canada en france ou même rythme que les
français à changer de président ou
reconduisent le mandat d'un président au
fait donc à tous les cinq ans mais ce
qui est étonnant parce que si c'est que
de ces depuis avril de l'année dernière
qu'on n'a plus de représentation au
niveau ambassade au rial ou à ce niveau
le plus tôt et ça c'est du jamais vu
d'enfants alors je peux bien comprendre
que on veut quand on veut si c'est le
cas on veut attendre l'élection du
nouveau président pour amener un nouveau
nouvelles personnes vous ambassadeurs en
poste en france pour redémarrer la
relation sabords mais entre les deux je
m'explique très mal comment on a accepté
de faire ça ça nous dit peut-être
quelque chose sur le poids des
diplomates francophones dans la grande
machine des affaires extérieures pour
talla c'est une mine est francophone qui
est l'art madame joly bref vous dites je
suis très étonné du tout sort bien et où
oui je suis étonné d'autant plus je
pense patrice nous n'avons qu'à regarder
lorsque madame charest a accepté c'est
toujours mal à me caresser la personne
qui était notre haut commissaire à
londres notamment en grande bretagne
elle est maintenant la greffière du
conseil exécutif ce conseil privé du
gouvernement du canada elle a été
remplacée dans l'espace de deux semaines
par ralph goodale qui était un ancien
ministre dans le gouvernement de
monsieur trudeau est depuis plusieurs
années déjà alors ça a pris deux
semaines pour remplacer cette personne
là il est sûr que on pourrait faire un
argumentaire assez forts qu'eux il n'y a
pas suffisamment de deux personnes dans
le dans le canada français au québec qui
pourrait assumer ses fonctions lors ben
voyons et suis pour certains encore je
suis prêt je suis pas prêt justement à
dire ça parce que il ya des hommes et
des femmes de qualité qui sont au québec
qui sont tous au canada et qui pourrait
très facilement assumer cette
responsabilité d'un bon mais lawrence
cannon merci nous avoir rappelé que
l'ambassade du canada à paris évident
non pas vis du personnel
mais en tout cas il n'ya pas d'ambassade
resoudde ambassadeur depuis un an dans
le scanner c'est quand même la politique
française est fascinante a analysé quand
même un petit mot avant de vous laisser
ouais c'est toujours fascinant
me viennent me vient à l'esprit notre
historien premier ministre qui m'avait
dit la beauté du système france c'est
qu'au premier tour déjà peuvent exprimer
une très grande frustration mais au
second tour tout le monde revient à une
forme de je dirais pragmatisme et donc
le frein de la france pardon se gouverne
d'herbe centre et ç'a toujours été le
cas et je serai fort surpris certes
monsieur macron pourra peut-être
diminuer
son niveau de deux matchs de majorité
mais je pense qu'un bout de pesto y sera
toujours le président de la république
dans l'est dans les prochaines semaines
lawrence cannon ancien ministre
conservateur ancien ambassadeur du
canada à paris c'était vous avez été là
2012 à 2017 je crois merci beaucoup nous
avons parlé ce un plaisir à la prochain
merci beaucoup au revoir
alors nous sommes mesdames et messieurs
en attente comme ce cas lundi un peu ce
que dit sur plusieurs formes depuis une
heure et demie deux ans c'est que il
peut le père mes oncles avantage est
nettement pour monsieur macron pour le
deuxième tour ln oui sont ce qu'on voit
c'est qu'il fait mieux qu'en 2017 au
premier tour et que l'écart surtout
entre lui et marine le pen est plus
important qu'il y a cinq ans depuis
quelques jours on était convaincus
qu'ils seraient tous les deux à
touche-touche si vous me permettez